bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne les travaux de la
commission des Lois du Sénat les
sénateurs ont organisé cette semaine
plusieurs tables rondes pour préparer
l'examen du projet de loi de réforme de
la décentralisation et de la métropole
alors ce matin deux exemples avec Lyon
et Marseille car si à Lyon et bien la
réforme devrait aboutir sans problème
d'ici à 2015 elle fait en effet l'objet
d'un consensus aussi bien à droite qu'à
gauche à Marseille et bien la réforme de
la métropole patine alors sans plus
tarder direction la salle clémençau pour
suivre deux tables rondes avec des élus
locaux Lyonnais et Marseillais bonne
matinée à tous je redis à nos amis de la
du rô et de Lyon et de l'agglomération
liyonnaise que nous sommes très heureux
de les accueillir avec notre rapporteur
de la commission des lois René Vand
renon ancien maire de roubé
vice-président de la Communauté urbaine
de l'île roubé tourcoin et homme de
dialogue donc c'est toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles il est bien sûr le
rapporteur voilà bien formé par Monsieur
diligent comme dit Monsieur Mercier bien
mais c'est la vérité on ne va pas dire
le contraire de la vérité n'est-ce pas
Jacqueline
bien alors euh nous avons le le plaisir
hein de vous de vous accueillir euh
représentant la mairie de Lyon euh la
mairie de villeorbane euh la mairie de
courtlaville euh le bureau de
l'association départementale des mares
d'Uron le Conseil générale madame la
Présidente et la région monsieur le
Président sans compter Monsieur Merci
qui est là divers
titre alors sur ce sujet euh peut-être
euh vais-je vous demander alors étant
entendu que tout est télévisé euh pour
nos
concitoyens que tout ce que vous allez
dire va paraître dans le rapport de
Monsieur vaniren donc donc je vous
propose de vous prendre dans cet ordre
non est-ce que ça vous
convient hein l'idée on peut on peut
commencer de gauche à droite de droite à
gauche l'idée
c'est que vous nous disiez en toute
franchise bien sûr ce que vous pensez du
projet de loi sur les métropole dans son
état actuel étant entendu qu'il a eu un
gros travail fait à Lyon
entre le département et
l'agglomération monsieur colon est en
déplacement mais on le verra par
ailleurs il est il est brillamment
représenté
donc nous savons qu'il y a eu beaucoup
de travail et nous avons aussi entendu
un certain nombre de paroles sur le
travail qui a été accompli donc nous
voulons ici vraiment entendre votre part
de vérité à chacun monsieur Mercier
peut-être monsieur le Président et
monsieur le sénateur merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre oui on va pu en finir sur
Jean-Jacques aussi monsieur le ministre
et vous-même monsurésid ou voilà ça ça
va faire un peu club donc on va éviter
de faire trop club moi je remercier le
président de la commission des lois le
rapporteur de nous avoir invité
aujourd'hui à parler sur le sujet
relatif au projet de Mét création d'une
métropole de Lyon euh je voudrais dire
des choses qui sont personnelles pour ma
part je soutiens un projet de métropole
de Lyon depuis longtemps je l'ai soutenu
devant la commission maladure devant la
commission Larché lorsque ces
commissions viennent faire des visites
au peuple de province vienent en général
à Lyon après avoir parlé longtemps à
Paris et j'ai soutenu la même thèse que
celle que je soutiens aujourd'hui et je
pense que on est arrivé à un moment où
il faut qu'on simplifie l'organisation
territoriale qu'on la rende plus
efficace et que nos concitoyens y aent
une petite part plus grande que celle
qui est la l'heure aujourd'hui tant on a
un système
complexe moi je suis heureux que le
gouvernement reprenne l'idée de
métropole il la prend quatre titres on
peut dire dans la loi d'une façon
générale pour créer des métropoles une
douzaine à peu près et puis trois
particulières une à Paris on vient
d'entend de parler ça pas l'air très
simple pour des gens qui ont
l'esprit assez simple hein une ex
Marseille et puis à Lyon à Lyon je vis
dire que c'est le projet le plus simple
le plus clair le plus facile à
comprendre nous créons nous proposons
nous avons proposé Gérard col et moi de
créer une collectivité territoriale
nouvelle qui est la métropole de Lyon et
par conséquent le département se retire
du territoire de la Communauté Urbaine
la métropole est un département o exerce
en tous les cas les compétences
départementales même si juridiquement il
faut se rattacher Linéa de l'article 72
de la Constitution et c'est donc une
collectivité de ce type qui est créée
avec la métropole euh moi j'adhère à
cette philosophie et je dis clairement
je suis heureux que le gouvernement ait
repris eu cette position j'espère qu'on
arrivera à la conduire cette métropole
sur les fond bâtisement de la réalité
juridique quelques mots supplémentaires
un c'est vrai qu'on l'a porté localement
largement le maire de Lyon et moi on
nous a reproché de l'avoir fait un peu
comment dire
spontanément
sans on va dire ça comme ça avec
peut-être pas pas assez de de discussion
préalable mais il y en avait eu en fait
beaucoup et puis je crois aussi que j'en
suis persuadé en tous les cas et je
l'assume que quand on est élu on est élu
pour faire quelque chose et que il faut
prendre ses responsabilités nous les
avons prises désormais si le Parlement
vote le projet que présente le
gouvernement il y aura une métropole de
Lyon qui sera qui exercera les
compétences du département 1350000
habitants à peu près et un département
du rô 440000 habitants à peu près si on
comprend la population municipal total
ou autrees mais à peu près cela 51e
département dirait à monsieur le
rapporteur que c'est un département qui
devrait lui parler puisqu'il va être
juste au
centre donc aucun problème de ce côté-là
de chaque côté il y aura autant de
départements avant et après en terme
démographique la question qui peut se
posé pour le département je parlerai
plus que de la métropole je pense que
c'est pas à moi de le faire mais pour ce
qui est du département la question qui
se posait c'est est-ce que le
département du rond futur sera un
département viable ou ou pas c'était la
question qui se posait en terme de
territoire il reste un petit département
2700 et quelques km
car mais il était déjà petit avant
440000 habitants un département qui
reste un département économiquement fort
industriel une croissance démographique
annuelle de 1,1 % c'est-à-dire un peu
plus que dans la métropole elle-même ce
qui se conçoit parfaitement avec les
problèmes fonciers que peut connaître la
métropole et département où les les
relations qui existent entre la
métropole et le département ben
continueront largement d'exister on va
pas construire un mur entre le
département et la métropole donc le
futur département du rô pourra continuer
à exister et un certain nombre de de
services communs en quelqu sorte
demeureront avec la métropole la loi en
prévoit au moins deux service des
archives service d'incend de secours et
je pense que dans le
protocole de négociation que nous menons
avec le grand liyon actuellement bah il
y aura d'autres services communs
notamment le PAC du rô probablement dans
le domaine culturel également d'autres
institutions resteront communes voilà
donc très BRI vement ce que je
souhaitais dire en guise d'introduction
une solution est offerte elle est elle
mérite de la clarté de la
simplicité un département une métropole
deux collectivités territoriales de la
République je vous ai parlé du
département deux mots sur la métropole
mais il y a des représentants plus
qualifiés que moi pour en parler je dois
dire
que l'essentiel du travail va devoir
peser sur la métropole pour s'organiser
pour exercer les compétences
départementales le département futur il
sait faire il a habitude notamment dans
le domaine social mais un exemple tout
simple actuellement nous avons 53000
personnes 56000 pardon personnes
bénéficiaires du RSA dans l'actuel
département du rô il y en aura un peu
moins de 8000 dans le futur département
et tous les autres seront dans la
métropole on voit
bien première difficulté
appréhender toutes ces personnes alors
que c'est pas un métier entre guillemets
actuellement assuré assumé par la
communauté urbaine de Lyon sur les
autres compétences on s'aperçoit qu'on
retrouve le partage démographique
partage démographique c'est 3/4 1/4 75
25 quand on regarde dépens pour
personnes handicapées c'est le plus gros
budget du département 240 millions
d'euros on retombe sur
74,9 et 25,1 donc on reste 25 quand on
regarde les personnes âgées et toute la
dépendance on est dans le
7525 on retombe sur le 7525 et la
question qui se pose pour le département
est-ce que les recettes fiscales seront
suffisantes deabord elles sont jamais
assez assez importante pour les
départements et le futur département du
rond connaîtra les mêmes difficultés que
les autres départements mais euh la loi
prévoit les mécanismes euh qui
permettent d'assurer euh le financement
euh des compétences exercées par chacune
des deux collectivités du point de vue
des compétences départementales par un
partage strict euh des recettes
correspondant aux dépenses au jour du
transfert avec une commission euh
présidée par la présidente de la Chambre
régionale des comptes et qui assurera
euh le l'équité du partage des recettes
il nous reste plus qu'à dire que pour ma
part moi je souhaite que le Parlement
bien entendu prenne tout son temps mais
pas plus si cela est possible et que les
électrices et les électeurs les citoyens
puissent être informé assez tôt que les
élections municipales
seront aussi pour les 1350000
hababitants de la métropole des
élections du futur conseil métropolitain
provisoire en quelque sorte puisque la
loi prévoit que son entrée en vigueur au
1er avril 2015 je pense qu'on déposera
un amendement parce que 1er avril c'est
moins bien que 1er janvier par exemple
mais que bien entendu pour la première
fournée du Conseil
métropolitain ce sont les conseillers
communautaires qui exerceront les
fonctions de conseiller métropolitain il
faudra attendre 2020 pour euh qu'il y
ait des conseillers métropolitains euh
réels après comme cela a été raelé tout
à l'heure dans le précédent la
présidente table ronde euh le Premier
ministre a fait des déclarations pour
nous euh c'est assez simple il y a deux
collectivités territoriales de la
République euh dans les deux cas euh et
ben il faut des élections euh de
conseils qui seront répondront aux
exigences constitutionnelles euh d'un
conseil administrant une collectivité
territoriale de la République pour le
futur département du rôe comme le
gouvernement que vous savez monsieur le
Président rapporteur a décidé de ne pas
augmenter le nombre des conseillers
départementaux par rapport au nombre des
conseillers généraux et que le
département du rô avait un petit conseil
général en terme de de membres de nombre
de conseillers généraux n étion
54 ce qui d'ailleurs suffisait bien dire
la vérité mais on va tomber euh grâce à
la règle du minimum posé dans la loi à
13 cantons pour le département de 440000
habitants 13 cantons euh d'abord c'est
un exercice intéressant de découpage euh
à faire comme toujours mais c'est quand
même pas beaucoup pour gérer un
département euh de cette importance mais
bon c'est comme ça c'est la loi on
l'appliquera euh et on va attendre de
connaître le découpage cararrêtera
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur même
s'il est pas impossible qu'on lui fasse
quelques suggestions intelligente et
qu'à ce titre il reprendra certainement
voilà monsieur le Président ce que je
pouvais dire en
introduction monsieur Mercier chers
collègues maintenant monsieur
Jean-Jacques keral monsieur le ministre
président du conseil régional de ronalpe
merci monsieur le Président d'abord
peut-être une
appréciation général sur les le texte et
les textes qui nous sont présentés pour
vous dire la déception que nous
éprouvons nous avons eu un débat au sein
de la région ronalp conseil régional qui
a duré une matinée je peux vous dire que
l'unanimité s'est dégagé pour dire que
ce texte n'était pas à la hauteur des
enjeux à hauteur des enjeux dans une
période de crise et dans une période où
il aurait fallu engager une nouvelle
étape de la
décentralisation les transferts faire de
compéten de la part de l'État sont
modestes ils sont encadrés on le voit
notamment sur la gestion des fonds
européens je pense aussi que ce n'est
pas clarification une simplification des
compétences ce qu'on aurait pu croire
attendre et en tout cas ça exprique le
sentiment qui est d'ailleurs je crois
assez largement partagé alors dans le
texte le premier texte qui viendra en
discussion avant d'aborder la question
des métropoles il y a deux sujets il y a
la question des chefs de fil et deuxième
sujet il y a la conférence territoriale
de l'action publique sur les chefs de
fil je rappellerai simplement en tant
que président de Région la nécessité de
souligner que la région est compétente
en matière d'aménagement du territoire
et et ça entraîne des conséquences
notamment sur le département qui s'est
vu attribuer dans le dernier round de
négociation le tourisme et l'aménagement
numérique du territoire
je pense que l'aménagement du territoire
inclut l'aménagement numérique je pense
que le développement économique inclut
le tourisme alors vous allez me dire
dans cette assemblée à forte connotation
départementale déshabiller le
département je pense que le
département a une compétence de
proximité je n'ai jamais été partisan de
la suppression des départements en
particulier dans une région comme la
région ronalp qui fait qui je
rappellerai grande comme la Suisse qui
est plus peuplée que le denemark j'ai
toujours dit que le département se
justifiait en tant collectivité de
proximité et je pense que la compétence
logement devrait revenir au département
tel que elle est organisée par ailleurs
pour les métropoles je crois qu'il y a
là une action de simplification quant à
la conférence sur territorial sur
l'action publique j'ai l'impression
qu'on réinvente ce qui existe déjà il y
a une conférence des exécutifs qui qui
se réunit Michel Mercier il participe
comme d'autres nous échangeons nous
pouvons prévoir des schémas de
simplification ça existe déjà je croiss
que la méthode qui nous est proposé avec
un
délai limité réduit pour répartir les
compétences en les mettant à l'ancamp ne
correspond pas à la mission du
législateur c'est au législateur de dire
quels sont les chefs de fil qui fait
quoi mais ce n'est pas un bon mode
d'organisation sur la les métropoles et
la métropole lyonnaise puisque nous
sommes aussi impactés par la question
des
métropoles étant donné que il peut y
avoir constitution d'une métropole à
Grenoble et que d'autre part il y a une
métropole transfrontalière qu'on appelle
maintenant le grand Genève qui est aussi
un élément
constitutif d'abord une réflexion
générale on voit en
terme de débat sur l'organisation
territoriale de la France mais je dirais
même d'abord sur l'évolution
territoriale de la France on voit de
écoles de géograp de sociologu euh pour
simplifier qui qui qui on des
perspectives différentes la première dit
le développement économique viendra des
métropoles c'est la locomotive qui
tirera tout le territoire c'est la
conception de davè c'est la conception
de VS c'est une conception qui est
prédominante au niveau gouvernemental et
en particulier au niveau de maqutigon et
puis il y a une deuxième
conception qui est celle donc développé
notamment par Christophe Julie par hois
Laurent qui dit attention aux fractures
du territoire attention au fait que les
inégalités territoriales risquent de se
développer et en mettant l'accent dès le
premier texte sur les métropoles je
pense que le gouvernement fait une
erreur par rapport à l'évolution du
territoire vous avez appelé à la vérité
moi je dis la vérité je pense qu'il
aurait été logique d'abord de parler de
l'égalité des territoires la solidarité
territoriale pour déboucher après sur
l'organisation du
territoire je crois aussi que cette
lecture économique est une lecture datée
parce que je pense aujourd'hui que
l'organisation économique se fait en
réseau et on le voit bien à travers
l'organisation des pôles de
compétitivité sur la région
renal donc il y a un ensemble
territorial qui contribue au
développement économique c'est une
conception datée qui relève de la
société ind
et pas de la société post-industrielle
de la société numérique se développeront
dans les temps qui viennent des formmees
de télétravail de téléorganisation qui
caractérise le territoire vouloir
concentrer l'effort économique et il en
résulte en particulier dans le deuxème
texte j'y reviendrai parce que dans ce
texte gogne il faut s'y retrouver
maintenant qu'il y en a trois
plutôt je pense que le développement
territorial en ce qui concerne en tout
cas la région ronalpe repose largement
sur la couverture du territoire au
niveau économique et donc ça c'est un
point qui est qui me paraît fondamental
et je le vois à travers l'existence
aujourd'hui des pôles de compétitivité
qui innerve le territoire et dire qu'on
veut les concentrer me paraît une erreur
donc à partir de
là la métropole lyonaise moi je dirais
oui d'ailleurs je l'ai toujours dit
Michel Mercier se rappelle que nous
avions des concordant en 2009 quand il y
a eu donc le rapport baladure l'avenue
d'Édouard baladure et puis la commission
Larché madame Gouro était là hein parce
que je pense que c'est un élément de
simplification de
lisibilité par rapport à l'organisation
le Conseil général a peu de visibilité
en milieu urbain parfois il y a une
certaine confusion qui peut exist des
tâches des rôles donc de ce point de vue
c'est une action de simplification donc
ça me paraît être un élément
positif je dis oui mais parce que je
crois que la région doit
rester le chef de fil du développement
économique et je pense que vouloir
établir un pouvoir concurrent entre la
région et la métropole et je dirais dans
le cas la région enalpe et les
métropoles me paraît destructeur en
matière de politique territoriale comme
en matière de politique économique parce
que le deuxème texte qui va
être discuté en
principe sur la croissance et l'emploi
et la promotion de l'égalité des
territoires dit dans son article 1 le
schéma régional de développement
économique d'innovation et
d'internationalisation prend en compte
la stratégie arrêtée sur leur territoire
par la métropole et dit les pôles de
compétitivité font l'objet d'un
copilotage entre d'une part l'État et
d'autre part les régions et les
métropoles qui sont pleinement associés
par l'État leur gouvernance on crée donc
dans le deuxème texte une situation
de concurrence qui à mon avis ne
correspond pas à la réalité je pense que
si l'on veut avoir développement
économique équilibré sur notre
territoire il faut des régions fortes et
des métropoles fortes mais le chef de
file en matière de développement
économique doit rester la région parce
qu'elle est garante justement sur une
grande région comme la nôre de
l'équilibre des territoires voilà moi ce
que je voulais dire les délégations de
compétences peuvent être réalisés il y a
pas lieu de modifier la loi parce qu'on
a l'impression que nous avons tous été
ministres qu'on réinvente chaque fois
l'eau chaude ou l'eau froide il y a un
texte qui s'appelle l'article L 11 11- 8
qui organise les délégation pourquoi
réécrire cette organisation de
délégation pourquoi réécrire dans le
chapitre métropole pas métropole de Lyon
Métropole un texte sur le chapitre
métropole qui d'ailleurs ne correspond
pas à la métropole de Lyon parce que le
lecteur un peu perspicace assidu
pourrait croire que les métropoles
auront plus de pouvoir que la métropole
de Lyon ce qui serait quand même assez
extraordinaire bon je pense que le Sénat
mettra un peu de cohérence dans ce texte
dont on voit bien qu'il a il résulte de
ciseaux multiples mais il y a il y a
donc cette possibilité qui est offerte
pourquoi aller chercher d'autres
formules et en particulier sur le texte
sur les les les métropole cette fois les
autres métropoles il est dit que la
région peut transférer les lycées ce qui
est absurde par rapport à la compétence
formation générale des régions à la
limite si les régions veulent le faire
elles le font sur la base des textes
existants de même en matière de
transfert économique donc je crois qu'il
faut pas jouer au chambou tout il y a un
texte qui existe il a ses mérites ses
vertus il permet les délégations et je
crois que tout le monde se portera bien
voilà donc monsieur le président oui
mais Monsieur le le monsieur le
Président de la Région vous avez avec
votre calme et sérénité habituelle dit
des choses très franches et je vous en
remercie je vois je suis approuvé par
Monsieur Paul vinelli j'en suis ravi
alors madame la présidente madame
Danielle chuseville présidente du
conseil général du
rô monsieur le Président je seraai assez
courte puisque au niveau du département
c'est naturellement monsieur Mercier qui
porte le bébé de cette métropole et du
nouveau département je voudrais
seependant ajouter à quel point c'est un
challenge pour nous de réussir à la fois
cette collectivité métropole et j'ai
bien entendu dans l'audition précédente
au niveau de Paris la question de
l'équité et pour moi c'est un des soucis
que la métropole garde cet esprit de
l'équité sur tout son territoire on a
effectivement des secteurs qui sont tout
à fait différents sur cette métropole
des secteurs riches des secteurs pauvres
tels que ça a été décrit pour Paris et
ce serait dommage vraiment dommageable
si ce qui a été construit sur le
département grâce en particulier à la
territorialisation ne ne pouvait servir
à la métropole donc ça c'est un enjeu
qui me semble un enjeu fort que sur tout
ce qui est solidarité et bien cette
esprit d'équité soit à nouveau et soit
toujours présent au niveau de la
métropole ce qui me paraît vraiment
important ensuite au niveau du
département et ce serait tout à fait
anormal de penser que le nouveau
département sera une copie de ce qui se
passait dans l'ancien département un
département de 450000 habitants n'est
pas un département d' 1700000 donc c'est
aussi un challenge de bâtir un nouveau
département avec peut-être une nouvelle
organisation territoriale mais qui soit
vraiment dans l'esprit d'une dynamique
alors dynamique économique le nouveau
départ ement comme l'a dit Michel
Mercier est un un département qui aura
vraiment du potentiel en lien avec
l'économie naturellement comme le vient
de dire le président de la région je
crois que c'est quelque chose qu'on a
vraiment à cœur de développer et cela ne
pourra se faire qu'en lien étroit avec
les EPCI et les communes d'autre part il
n'y aura pas de mur de Berlin si je puis
dire entre la métropole et le
département et il faudra bien que l'on
arrive à construire au-delà de ce qui
est dans le texte tel que le 10 ou les
archives départementales des passerelles
entre la métropole et le département
tous les atouts culturels que nous avons
dans le département sont situés les
atouts culturels forts sont situés sur
la métropole et ce serait vraiment
dommageable si ces atouts culturels
forts ne pouvaient servir au
développement culturel du nouveau
département donc c'est là aussi quelque
chose qui nous paraît vraiment important
de d'avoir ceci en mémoire lorsque nous
allons établir cette construction entre
nouveau département et métropole d'autre
part nous avons aussi une question qui
sera clé c'est la répartition des
personnel 5400 personnes 5400 agents
4000 vers la métropole 1500 à peu près
vers le département et bien ça sera
effectivement une nouvelle
décentralisation si on peut dire et cela
ne peut pas se faire sans une étude fine
et évidemment avec les agents voilà ce
qui me paraissait important pour ce qui
concerne le
département bien merci beaucoup madame
la la présidente alors monsieur
Jean-Paul Brett vous êtes le maire de
ville orbane qui est une ville à
laquelle nous sommes tous très attachés
pour des raisons
culturelles des raisons
architecturales et des raisons sportives
non mais je dis ça parce que voyez
quelque fois on dit Lyon moi je dis il y
a Lyon c'est important hein Monsieur
l'Adjoint et villeorbane c'est très
important alors voulez pas faire ce
débat sans vous
entendre merci de de m'avoir invité
votre introduction me comble mais c'est
vrai parce que je crois qu'il était
effectivement important dans dans un
débat sur l'organisation future de la
métropole de Lyon que la deuxième ville
du
département pourrait le dire enfin même
si les choses vont changer je je le dis
quelquefois il s'agit pas de de se
gonfler mais nous sommes la première des
en France des deuxè villes dans une
agglomération puisque avec près de
150000 habitants nous sommes la 19e
ville de France et quelquefois je fais
la comparaison avec la capitale
régionale voisine ClermontFerrand qui
est plus petite que ville orbane et vous
avez souligné à juste titre qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'éléments de l'histoire
de cette ville que ce soit en matière
culturelle en matière sportif qui compte
et donc à partir de là évidemment nous
nous pouvons nous situer dans le projet
de métropole que d'une manière un peu
exigeante et et et ne pas rentrer dans
ce qui pourrait apparaître comme un
processus un peu de subalternis je sais
pas si le terme existe enfin voilà et
c'est c'est là l'essentiel de mon propos
alors pour faire simple pour faire
simple je reviens sur ce qu'a dit Michel
Mercier le je crois que le consensus est
assez large jeanan l'a repris à son
niveau même s'il a apporté beaucoup
d'éléments de critique sur l'ensemble du
processus qui est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui sur le territoire ce qui
est le territoire urbain ils reviennent
demain à ce qu'en gros le fait urbain
s'impose et ce qui était de la
compétence du Département dans le
territoire de la Communauté Urbaine
appelons encore les choses comme elle
s'appelle encore aujourd'hui puissent
être transféré en quelque sorte avec
beaucoup de problèmes à prendre en
compte à cette communauté urbaine et
demain à cette métropole là-dessus ça
fait assez largement consensus pas sur
tous les bans politiques mais quand même
je crois très très largement en revanche
là où j'étais amené à à m'exprimer d'une
façon plus réservée plus critique et je
vais je vais le faire à nouveau devant
vous aujourd'hui
c'est sur la façon aujourd'hui dont dont
dont ce projet de loi a été rédigé enfin
la façon et je pense qu'il est pas tout
à fait non plus il ne correspond pas
exactement à cette chose simple la chose
simple c'est on transfère à la
communauté urbaine et demain à la
métropole ce qui relève aujourd'hui du
département sur ce territoire
aujourd'hui une lecture attentive du
texte même pas pas forcément très
attentive d'ailleurs en regardant
l'essentiel des choses montre euh qu'il
y a un certain nombre de choses qui sont
transférées des communes alors d'une
part la collectivité va devenir une
collectivité territoriale ce qui est pas
un changement mince actuellement c'est
une EPCI donc ça porte à terme quand
même un certain nombre de choses il faut
quand même les mesurer et il y a dans ce
projet de loi je dirais on en a profité
sans savoir qui en a profité d'ailleurs
c'est sans doute même quelquefois que
personne ne l'a vraiment fait ce qui
rend souvent les choses plus difficiles
parce que je ne pense pas que ça soit
ceux qui en ont été les promoteurs
Michel Mercier et Gérard colon en tout
cas lorsqu'on en parle avec lui qui est
qui est avancé sur ce sujet-l et que ça
va même au contraire d'un discours j'ai
quelquefois qualifié d'un peu lénifiant
mais en tout cas apaisant qui était dire
ça ne change rien aux communes ce n'est
pas vrai ça change un certain nombre de
choses au communes et la lecture de ce
projet de loi montre alors il y a déjà
le fait que ça devienne une collectivité
territoriale avec ce que ça implique
derrière et puis quand on lit je sais
plus à quel article mais peu importe les
choses qui sont transférées on
s'aperçoit qu'on va bien au-delà de ce
qui est exercé aujourd'hui par la
Communauté Urbaine la communauté urbaine
de Lyon elle a quand même pour
caractéristique contrairement à d'autres
intercommunalités d'avoir déjà poussé
loin le transfert des compétences d'une
part parce qu'elle existe depuis
1970 6 voilà merci de me corriger un peu
enfin ça change pas grand-chose à
l'échelle
d'aujourd'hui et elle a donc poussé loin
transfèt des compétences elle les a même
complété récemment quelquefois dans le
processus qui était le nôre c'est-à-dire
avec l'accord 2/ers des populations ou
des conseils municipaux enfin voilà dans
un processus en tout cas je dirais
démocratique ou dans lequel les communes
étaient représenter à travers leur
conseil municip or ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui et c'est là que je souhaite
vraiment je le dis avec force ici comme
jean-jaces kirane l'a dit pour les
régions je souhaite vraiment que ce
texte soit profondément modifié sur un
certain nombre de points sinon il dupe
un peu par rapport à à ce qui est
l'esprit initial du texte enfin de de
plutôt du du projet tel que Michel
Mercier d'ailleurs laa rappeler pourquoi
parce que quand on regarde les choses
bon on s'aperçoit que euh on voit le je
sais plus quel est le chapitre qui
commence la communauté enfin excusez-moi
la métropole je dis la communauté
urbaine la métropole exerce en lieu et
place des communes donc c'est dit
clairement en lieu et place des communes
et suite toute une énumération alors il
y a ce qui relevait autrefois de la
enfin ce qui relève encore de la
communauté urbaine et ces choses-là ne
font pas problème puisque voilà mais il
il y a plus il y a un certain nombre
d'autres choses et j'en cite simplement
quelquesuns parce qu'on pe peut-être du
plus du plus général au au plus simple
en tout cas au plus focalisé donc il y a
déjà puisque Jean-Pierre surur a parlé
de de la culture pour me donner la
parole on voit que les établissements
d'intérêt métropolitain seraient si on
s'en tient à l'aspect normatif de la loi
serait transféré à la future métropole
ça change beaucoup de choses nous avons
alors je dis encore un équipement qui
est thâre national populaire qui est
intimement lié à l'histoire de la ville
dans son rapport au pouvoir politique
Catherine taska était là tout à l'heure
et LAN sait quelque chose quand elle
était ministre de la Culture il est sûr
qu'une ville comme ville Bane n'envisage
pas sereinement de se voir dépouiller
par la métropole d'un établissement
culturel qui contribue aussi fortement à
son identité on pourrait le faire de la
même façon dans le domaine sportif alors
tout ça ne ne n'empêche pas de
mutualiser de travailler ensemble je
crois que la communauté urbaine le
montre mais passer dans une espèce de
tutelle de la métropole alors bien sûr
les propos aujourd'hui sont dire mais on
va conventionner ça ne changera rien or
la loi elle est faite pour dire les
choses dans la façon dont elles vont se
passer bien au-delà de nous et de ceux
qui sont autour de cette table donc elle
ne peut pas être faite simplement à un
moment donné pour répondre à des soucis
légitimes d'exercice d'une gouvernance
donc il faut penser à ça donc je je je
trouve que la loi la impose une norme
qui est un vrai bouleversement dans le
rapport qu'on les communes avec un
certain nombre d'éléments je cite le cas
de la culture mais on pourra en citer
d'autres euh de de de ce qu' de ce
qu'elles ont de ce qu'elles gèrent
aujourd'hui autre exemple que j'ai cité
également et je je réécrirai je vous
repasserai pour rentrer un peu plus dans
le détail c'est celui de du pouvoir de
police des maires ça c'est assez
ahurissant parce que euh là derrière une
volonté qui est affichée de
simplification d'un 1lefeuille hein que
tout le monde s'en gargarise un peu on
simplifie on simplifie donc au nom de la
simplification tout est bon euh on crée
une police métropolitaine avec comme
logique alors c'est une logique
d'apparent bon sens qui est de dire dans
la mesure où la communauté la métropole
pardon mais la communauté urbaine l'a
déjà aujourd'hui exerce les compétences
en matière de voirie et de stationnement
ce que personne ne remet en cause elle
doit demain exercer elle doit avoir une
police qui permettent de faire cela or
aujourd'hui ça ne se passe pas comme ça
aujourd'hui la la communauté urbaine à
la voir stationnement et les polices
restent des polices municipales au grand
plaisir de chacun donc personne ne remet
cela en cause donc pourquoi la loi a mis
là-dedans je ne sais pas d'où ça vient
mais en tout cas ça ne vient ni de
Michel Mercier ni de Gérard colonb pour
les citer donc c'est arrivé autrement
bon il peut y avoir quelques je ne sais
pas et donc je reprends cet exemple là
parce qu' il est l'exemple le plus
absurde ça signifierait qu'il y aurait
demain une police municipale qui
resterait avec des problèmes de sécurité
qu'à la police municipale il y aurait
une police métropolitaine pour la voirie
et le stationnement et puis une police
nationale euh peut-être pour les taxis
oui non et on voit bien qu'en tout cas
en matière puisque le cœur quand même de
cette de ce projet de loi c'est quand
même l'efficacité de l'action publique
c'est pas seulement la décentralisation
c'est plutôt l'efficacité l'amélioration
de l'action publique sur lequel nous
sommes plutôt tous d'accord on
s'aperçoit qu'ici en faisant une strate
supplémentaire bah voilà on rend les
choses plus compliquées moins
efficaces c'est du personnel en plus
terme alors là-dessus c'est clair alors
qu'aujourd'hui dans une ville où il y a
une police municipale bien sûr elle
assure la VO stationnement et elle
assure d'autres tâche donc c'est ça
mutualiser d'une certaine action
l'action publique sur un territoire donc
voilà si vous voulez quand on regarde la
loi dans dans le détail enfin dans les
articles on voit cela il y a un certain
nombre d'autres exemples je les cite
simplement pour ne pas rentrer dans le
détail qui est le les dispositifs de
prévention de la délinquence avec les
conseils locaux qui existent qui
fonctionnent bien quand les communes ont
pris la peine de les mettre en place qui
est le cas chez nous en faire un
dispositif centralisé à l'échelle de la
métropole c'est a priori pas une bonne
idée donc faire ça on le retrouve aussi
dans un certain nombre d'autres cas que
j'ai j'ai cité dans une note
euh au-delà des polices bon peu importe
je j'en ai tout une liste à égrainer
voilà après donc voilà mon donc
l'essentielle de mon propos là et de
dire ce n'est pas vrai que cette loi ne
change rien aux communes elle les empute
d'une part importante de leur
responsabilité les communes sont prêtes
à l'exercer de manière mutualisée il
s'agit pas d'être chacun replié sur son
territoire derrière ses frontières mais
laissons laissons puisqu'on a parlé
d'expérimentation laissons les choses se
faire comme elles se sont faites un peu
jusqu'à maintenant c'est-à-dire lorsque
l'on voudra transférer des compétences
parce que nous les streamerons utiles
chois nous choisirons nous-mêm les
formes de mutualisation elles ne seront
pas des formes normative imposé par la
loi donc ça c'est un point essentiel et
il faut vraiment je crois que enfin
c'est mon S sentiment je suis pas
sénateur donc je pourrais pas suivre
d'aussi près que d'autres l'évolution du
texte de loi mais il faut vraiment que
ces choses-là il y ait des amendements
important qui bouleverse un petit peu la
façon dont ce texte a été construit sur
le département je
et je suis nous sommes évidemment
intéressés aussi par le transfert des
compétences du département à la à la
future métropole là aussi y a
quelquefois dans le texte des choses qui
sont rentrées dans le détail donc je
pense qu'elle mériterait aujourd'hui
d'être discuté à l'échelon euh
département future métropole et non pas
inscrit dans le texte avec des des
choses aussi un peu absurdes qui est que
par exemple tout ce qui relève de l'aide
sociale aujourd'hui est indiqué comme
étant transfè possiblement transféré aux
communes via une délégation alors que ce
sont plutôt des compétences je pense o
il faut garder un certain nombre de
distance entre le politique on sait bien
hein les travailleurs sociaux euh je
veux dire ils exercent leur métier il on
pas envie d'avoir une présence aussi
forte alors qu'au contraire des secteurs
comme le la PMI la petite enfance dans
lequel les communes des ont des
équipements gérent des personnels font
de l'action politique au contraire
celle-ci reste de la compétence de la
métropole je je ne comprends pas comment
euh je veux dire un tel inversement des
choses a pu être inscrit dans la loi
voilà donc voilà si vous voulez moi
l'essentiel de mon propos il ne faudrait
pas qu'au prétexte de ce qui est un un
un bon propos je le répète qui est de de
passer les compétences du département
sur le territoire urbain on en arrive à
une évolution aujourd'hu our'hui de la
métropole qui subalternise enfin qui
fasse que les communes et les grandes en
particulier bien sûr chacun parle à
travers son expérience c'est bien normal
que le maire de la deuxème grande ville
le ressente peut-être différemment celui
d'autres que les maires d'autres
communes il faudrait pas qu'on
aille dans le sens contraire d'un
certain nombre d'objectifs qui sont
affichés dans les propos de cette loi
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Maire je vais
donner monsieur jean-pa je vais donner
la parole à David Kimelfeld qui est
adjoint au maire de Lyon et
vice-président du grand lion Monsieur
l'Adjoint au Maire merci Monsieur le
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur de de cette
audition puis aussi pour dire je suis il
se trouve maire d'un arrondissement
lyonnais qui lui avait encore un rempart
avec la ville de Lyon il y a à peu près
160 ans donc je sais ce que c'est aussi
que l'identité d'un d'une ville ou d'un
arrondissement et la manière dont les
choses peuvent c'est la croixousse oui
c'est important voilà juste dire que
cette loi pour nous est d'abord et vous
l'avez dit je crois que les intervenants
l'ont dit le fruit d'une histoire
d'abord c'està d'une histoire de cette
communauté urbaine qui est née en 1966
je le rappelle quelque part sous la
contrainte de l'État communes c'était
pour régler des problématiques
d'assainissement des goûts et des choses
comme ça que derrière c'est le fruit
aussi d'un territoire qui a beaucoup
évolué et jeanjacqu Iran l'a dit
Jean-Paul BR l'a dit avec des des
compétences qui au fur à mesure des des
années se sont se sont retrouvé au grand
lion avec la volonté du grand lion de
les prendre je pense je pense à
l'urbanisme je pense au transport je
pense je pense à la politique de
l'habitat et puis aussi c'est le fruit
aussi je crois d'une volonté politique
s'il y a
aujourd'hui une spécificité métropole de
Lyon et pour ça que nous sommes réunis
aussi c'est parce qu'il y a une volonté
politique je rappelle que Gérard Colomb
président du grand lion lors de son
premier
discours comme président du Gron avait
évoqué déjà cette affaire de métropole
et c'est pour ça que nous avons aussi
dans l'exécutif un viceprésid président
en charge de ces questions de la
métropole donc il y a d'abord une vraie
volonté du terrain il y a une volonté
politique d'aller sur cette sur cette
métropole dire finalement qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que l'on veut je pense qu'on
aura peut-être l'occasion de rentrer
tout à l'heure peut-être dans les
détails et d'un certain nombre de choses
qui ont été dites là c'est sans faire
trop de slogan c'est un on pourra
débattre avec Jean-Jacques kan tout à
l'heure des écoles des d'économistes de
savoir qui tire la région je crois qu'il
y a un peu un peu de tout là-dedans
simplement N qu'est-ce qu'on veut on
veut on veut un territoire qui soit en
même temps compétitif qui s'inscrive
dans cette
compétition européenne des métropoles
Patrick brousek l'a dit tout à l'heure
mais en même temps on le veut avec la
cohésion sociale c'est d'où l'intérêt de
cette métropole là c'est d'avoir
effectivement la compétitivité et
d'avoir les outils de la cohésion
sociale c'est d'avoir les outils de
l'attractivité en même temps d'avoir les
outils de la solidarité et puis d'avoir
aussi ça répond en partie à un certain
nombre d'interrogations qu'il faudra
peut-être améliorer dans le texte
d'avoir une stratégie partagé et d'avoir
le souci de de la de la proximité voilà
les les les les les les grands les
grandes les grands slogans qui nous
pousse à cette sur cette sur cette loi
et puis il y a aussi un élément on l'a
bien vu tout à l'heure c'est la
possibilité d'expérimenter et d'innover
je crois que ce que montre un certain
nombre d'articles dans cette loi c'est
qu'on peut expérimenter un certain
nombre de choses y compris et bien
évidemment avec les communes notamment
un certain nombre de compétences du
département qui peuvent être tout à fait
je crois qui sont nécessaires à être
dévolu aux communes on aura peut-être
l'occasion as tout à l'heure de
l'évoquer notamment en matière d'action
sociale ou d'autres d'autres sujets moi
ce que je peux dire à ce stadelà c'est
aussi de dire que c'est quand même un
projet extrêmement parce que là on a
évoqué un peu les choses je trouve un
peu de manière un peu pesante mais c'est
peut-être la température de la salle je
trouve que c'est quelque chose d'assez
enthousiasment et d'assez excitant pour
les pour les élus de du territoire et je
crois qu'il faut quand même aussi le
dire c'est pas souvent quand on a des
élus de collectivité qui sont comment
dire excités par de nouveaux projets je
crois que qu' faut insister d'abord
là-dessus c'est que c'est effectivement
très excitant avec bien évidemment comme
Jean-Paul Bret l'a dit un certain nombre
de choses à améliorer un certain nombre
de choses à corriger comme l'a dit
Jean-Jacques kiram comme l'a dit Michel
Mercier et Daniel chusville mais en tout
cas la première chose à dire je crois
c'est cette cette volonté cet
enthousiasme qu'on les élu pour aller
vers cette vers cette métropole et puis
vers ce vers ce nouveau département moi
je va pas rentrer tout de suite dans les
détail sur les communes je crois que la
volonté mais Jean-Paul Brett l'a dit
bien évidemment du président aujourd'hui
du Grand lon c'est pas d'aller euh
préempter tout ce qui se fait sur les
communes au contraire je crois que c'est
d'aller travailler avec les communes
pour qu'on puisse avec les communes
retrouver un certain nombre de missions
qu'avait le Conseil général pour les
retrouver directement sur le territoire
c'est déjà quelque part ce qui existe un
peu dans un certain nombre de communes
notamment à travers les CCAS quand quand
quand on est sur des communes de de
taille moyenne où on a déjà dans la même
pièce finalement et je me tourne vers
madame chuseville et vers monsieur
Mercier dans la même pièce le CC la
maison du département tout ça travaille
déjà ensemble c'est pas le cas dans les
dans dans nos grandes villes de la
métropole ça sera demain le cas comment
est-ce qu'on travaille cette proximité
là donc je crois que ça c'est
extrêmement important sur la région
rapidement j'en parle avec d'autant plus
de facilité que j'ai en charge les le
développement économique sur ce
territoire là donc je travaille en
étroite collaboration avec avec mon
homologue Jean-Louis gagère à la région
je crois que bien évidemment jean-jacqu
kirane l'a dit il faut une région forte
pour qu'on ait une métropole forte ce
travail de collaboration étroite il est
c'est déjà le cas dans notre dans notre
sur notre territoire parce que le grand
lon travaille en étroite collaboration
avec
avec avec la région sur les différents
sujets on a évoqué les pôles de
compétitivité on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en d' d'en évoquer d'autres
et donc on est déjà dans cette dans
cette collaboration là dans des systèmes
qui nous permettent bien évidemment de
partager une stratégie il y a un chef de
fil c'est la région euh on peut pas dire
que on soit enfin dans les 4 ans que je
viens de vivre moi dans dans dans dans
des sujets où nous n n'ayons pas été
d'accord sur le la stratégie de
développement économique sur l'échelle
sur l'échelle du Grand lon donc après la
réalité c'est ça c'est que on s'est mis
d'accord et le grand lon Jean-Jacques
kirane le disait finance aussi avec la
région de manière beaucoup plus modeste
je crois que c'est sur les 10 dernières
années c'est une centaine de millions
d'euros c'est en moyenne 15 millions
d'euros par an sur les dernières sur les
dernières années les pôle de
compétitivité on le fait toujours en
cofinancement ça veut dire que ces
processus de de de de décision de
décision se se se se se se discute avec
avec avec la région voilà ce que je
voulais dire dans des propos mais
surtout ce que je souhaitais faire
passer comme message
c'est une volonté et après ici ou là il
y a des outils on les verra peut-être
tout à l'heure la conférence locale des
maires comment est-ce qu'on fait évoluer
ça il y a le pacte le pacte de
gouvernance dans les 6 premiers mois
enfin il y a un certain nombre d'outils
qui doivent nous amener aussi des
garanties pour que les choses se fassent
de la manière la plus harmonieuse mais
je crois que le message aussi c'est que
bien évidemment nous tenons absolument à
conserver c'est bien
évident la commune comme l'échelon de de
proximité qui qu'on peut pas qu'on peut
pas nier bien évidemment voilà
merci Monsieur le Maire Monsieur
l'Adjoint David kimelffeld c'est vrai
que au début de la séance à 2h 14h j'ai
dit notre enthousiasme d'être là pour
parler d'un projet de loi avec des élus
qui ont des points de vue différents
s'agissant de Paris de Lyon et dans
quelques moments de Marseille et puis
après on va rencontrer encore d'autres
associations Marseille ex oui oui bien
sûr nousous nous sommes très intéressés
nous ne sommes pas du tout vous le voyez
bien dans la tristesse au contraire
c'est très intéressant donc nous
écoutons tout le monde et nous essaions
de de de faire notre travail de
parlementaire au mieux alors Monsieur le
Député hein Monsieur Patrice Vercher
député du Rône maire de courlaville et
vous êtes aussi représentant ici de
l'Association des Maires du rô alors
Monsieur le Député merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur je
voudrais tout d'abord excuser ellisabeth
Lamur votre collègue sénateur et
présidente de l'association
départementale qui ne pouvait être
présent aujourd'hui donc moi je voudrais
limiter mes propos essentiellement à la
métropole et et le département
simplement vous dire que le
l'association départementale n'a pas
pris position pour le moment ni
favorable ni défavorable mais on ressent
quand même une position qui est plutôt
favorable avec un certain nombre
d'inquiétude bon il est vrai que la
présentation qui a été faite au mois de
novembre par Michel Mercier est et par
Gérard colon a pu être considéré par
certains comme un peu abrupte mais
peut-on faire une réforme de cette
importance sans
l'annoncer en la préparant trop tôt je
pense pas donc je pense que c'est plutôt
une bonne chose mais cétait un peu ce
qui avait été ressenti à un moment donné
donc je tenais quand même à le dire
puisque je représente les maires du
département ensuite je crois qu'il y a
plus d'inquiétude de la part des maires
issu de cette future métropole du Grand
lon sur l'avenir de leur commune ils
savent qu'en 2015 et 2014 les élection
2014 bon les communes existeront encore
mais quid de 2020 il y a beaucoup de
questionnements sur l'avenir des
communes en 2020 il y a des
questionnements également sur la
gouvernance et notamment la conférence
locale des maires puisque quand on lit
le texte on voit que cette conférence
locale peut être réunie peut être
consultée lors de l'élaboration et de la
mise en uvre des politiques de la
métropole donc là aussi le fait que
c'est peuvent voilà c'est on aimerait
bien peut-être que ça soit un peu plus
précis elle se réunit mais il y a pas
d'obligation annuelle est-ce qu'il faut
rendre une l'obligation peut-être pas
trimestrielle mais au moins semestriel
parce que les maires ça a été dit par le
représentant du du maire de Lyon c'est
aussi l'échelle de proximité la commune
et même à l'intérieur de l'agglomération
je crois que c'est important que dans la
conférence locale ça soit pas le
règlement intérieur qui fasse justement
la règle de des réunions et et les
moments où ça se réunit que ça soit
déterminé dans la loi de manière précise
l'obligation de se réunir au moins au
moins deux fois par an ensuite en ce qui
concerne plutôt
les le reste du département on peut dire
que les gens sont très très attaché et
là on voit qu'il y a eu un travail en
amont de fait notamment par par Michel
Mercier sur le maintien du service
départemental et de secours dans le
département du rond tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire demain
métropole plus département je crois que
c'est important parce que suite à la
départementalisation il y a eu un
travail important effectuer sur
l'ensemble du département cela marche
bien et il ne faudrait pas casser ce qui
marche bien donc je crois que c'est
important cet article qui qui est prévu
soit maintenu en l'état ensuite on peut
dire que il y a une inquiétude de des
maires du futur nouveau département
c'est sur le financement je crois que
Michel Mercier a rappelé il y a un
instant que cela devrait pas poser de
problème je pense qu' ils attendent
aussi des chiffres un peu plus précis
alors c'est un peu toujours difficile
parce qu'on en demande beaucoup C ces
temps-ci
au au représentant des des finances
publiques mais je crois que c'est
important alors c'est vrai que le
département du rô avec sa présidente
Danielle chuseville a commencé à
répondre à ces inquiétudes depuis
vendredi puisqueun certain nombre de de
réunions se passent d'informations sur
l'ensemble du département je pense que
c'est une bonne chose et puis il y a
également une inquiétude sur le
financement j'en ai parler euh oui c'est
pas une inquiétude non je pense que les
gens sont plutôt satisfaits suite au
vote de la loi la semaine dernière
définitive euh au Parlement sur la
création notamment du binôme donc je
sais que le Sénat n'était pas favorable
parce que il est très clair enin une
partie
en en tout cas le Sénat était plutôt
défavorable sur cette affaire là
majoritairement défavorable voilà c'est
bien donc ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que le binôme quand on explique
aux élus des département du Rône que si
la métropole lyonnaise ne se fait pas il
y aura des cantons de 70000 habitants
sur le département du rô autant dire que
le rô rural ou semirural est fini moi
j'avais parlé d'une roit rural icide je
maintiens mais c'est vrai que là il y
avait une vraie inquiétude et le fait
qu'il a la création de cette métropole
reviendra à des cantons
approximativement de 30000 habitants et
corespondra plus à à la réalité de ce
département qui c'est vrai a une grosse
aglomération j'ai pas trop d'inquiétude
sur le fait de du travail effectué en
commun entre ces deux collectivités
futures puisque là se fait depuis des
décennies et que il est normal que cela
continue j'aurais une question alors
plus de parlementaires vu qu'il y a la
création de deux collectivité locale
cuide de la représentation parlementaire
de ces collectivités est-ce que ça reste
en état ou parce que le texte nen parle
pas du tout où est-ce qu'il y a des
représentants de la collect sénatoriale
et des puté du département du Rône
précis et des représentants de la de la
métropole lyonnaise sénateur et députés
pourquoi je dis ça parce que à l'heure
actuelle sur les 14 parlementaires
députés sur le Rône il n'y a qu'un
parlementaire qui n'a pas une partie de
l'agglomération lyonnaise dans sa
circonscription les 1 autres ont un
morceau d'agglomération lyonnaise donc
est-ce que cela sera resté en l'état ou
est-ce qu'il y aura une repr
ité de cette nouvelle collectivité que
sera la métropole pure et une
représentativité pure de ce nouveau
département voilà ce que je tenais à
vous dire Monsieur le Maire vous savez
qu'en tant que député vous représentez
la nation donc ne vous préoccupez pas
trop de tous ces découpag je vous dis
aussi que par rapport au rural
icide vous savez que le Conseil
constitutionnel et le Conseil d'État ont
pris des décisions qui s'appliquent à
tous c'estàd on est obligé de respecter
la démographie alors on peut l' aimer
pas aimer mais c'est un peu neutre parce
que quel que soit le gouvernement on est
obligé on peut pas alors bon mais c'est
un autre débat monsieur Mercier que nous
avons eu que nous aurons pire que le
gouvernement socialiste le gouvernement
des juges
oui monsieur Mercier dit procèsverbal
mais non on peut le mettre dans le
procès-verbal il dit qu'il y a pire que
le gouvernement socialiste c'est le
gouvernement des juges mais puisque vous
l'avez dit autant le dire
mais Monsieur Merci on a vu toutes
sortes de gouvernement vous savez on a
pu se faire une idée bien alors
amicalement donc alors ceci étant dit
nous allons passer amicalement la parole
à notre rapporteur monsieur René Viren
donc alors à mon tour de vous remercier
d'être venu si nombreux j'avais lu Lyon
magazine donc je connaissais bien les
épithètes utilisées par les uns et les
autres he pour qualifier
le le projet
euh ceci
étant j'entends bien que monsieur le
Président Keran dit un oui
euh donc j'ai plutôt envie de travailler
sur le le ma
hein parce que je crois quand même que
cette
réforme a quand même l'immense mérite
d'exister et et très
honnêtement il y a une ambiguïé dans le
texte il y a beaucoup d'ambiguïé
d'ailleurs dans ce texte d'une manière
générale he il y en a une première qui
tient au
Sénat qui est que si ce texte a été
saucissonné c'est parce que quand même
des sénateurs ont souhaité qu'il le soit
alors c'est quand même quelque chose
faut dire je suis tout nouveau mais
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
troublant de se retrouver dans le même
Sénat et de voir les mêmes sénateurs qui
ont demandé le sauciss son dire euh oh
ça serait tellement mieux si tout était
d'un seul
bloc donc ça ça méritait d'être dit
puisque tout est enregistré hein
euh la la la la
deuxè la deuxième chose sur
lequelle il faut qu'on qu'on soit clair
c'est que métropole métropole ça fait
floresse comme un un nouveau produit de
marketing mais il y a un double sens
dans le texte faut le dire en entrée de
jeu
on a tous quelques heures de vol dans la
gestion de ces collectivités donc euh où
il s'agit on peut contester la théorie
du développement économique où il s'agit
au sens je vais dire
Eurostat de trouver un élément de
motorisation du développement économique
d'intégration recherche innovation et
application dans le développement
économique qui puisse dire il faut pour
relever ce défi là euh atteindre une
sorte de taille critique et he ce que
vous avez commencé à dire dans ce que le
gouvernement dans le texte dit que ça
hein
euh c'est ça peut être contesté en tous
les cas brausek le disait tout à l'heure
moi j'appartiens à cette école là faut
qu'on le sache c'est-à-dire que
l'intérêt de la métropole et je pense
que ronalp a ces lettres de gloire
l'intérêt de la métropole c'est de
porter une stratégie de développement
économique intégré mais c'est aussi de
porter au niveau de l'habitat comme au
niveau de la cohésion sociale une
politique qui considère que
développement et solidarité forme ce
qu'en mécanique on appelle un couple
c'est ce qu'a dit brausek tout à l'heure
avec
l'inclusif à partir de là
euh s'il y a une métropole qui
incontestablement et même si Paris
rayonnement mondial et cetera au niveau
intégration sil y a une métropole qui
peut être citée quand même en exemple
c'est que d'une
initiative que je considère positive oui
mais on va y venir c'est bien vous bon
moi c'est ce que je pense c'est pour ça
que j'ai pris un peu par défi he sachant
que il fallait un gabarit de
Saint-Sébastien pour y aller bon c'est
pour ça que j'ai pris le le défi de dire
essayons de de tenter ça maintenant ce
qui m'intéresse c'est comment à partir
de là on évite que le Conseil régional
ne voit fr agilisé parce que je
considère que c'est fondamental aussi on
a reçu
récemmentos vos vice-présidents sur le
foncier foncier dont on parle dans le
texte et on sait ce qui est fait aussi
par le Conseil régional dans ce domaine
donc moi je voulais vous dire que dans
le laps de temps que l'on m'a donné qui
est court mais monsieur le Président de
la Commission des loi qui est un un
optimiste heureusement d'ailleurs c'est
comme ça qu'on tient euh nous dit tu
aura au moins quatre lectures dans ce
texte hein moi je sais qu'il y avait pas
des municipales et l'érection de cette
collectivité en collectivité
territoriale je pense que ce
texte
connaîtrait une un rythme moins soutenu
hein quelque chose me me me me me le dit
comme ça he donc moi je je vais faire je
vais faire avancer les choses au mieux
sur ce que
pense monsieur Bret il y a eu un
comparaison n'est pas raison hein mais
là aussi on a on est prêt à travailler
je veux quand même dire
que c'est pas tout à fait irrationnel de
chercher à poser parce que c'est quand
même une question pendante à chaque fois
qu'on fait progresser
l'intercommunalité de chercher à voir
comment on peut stratégiquement intégrer
des compétences et dans leur mise en
œuvre dans leur mise en œuvre
respectecter comme un sacro c'est un
principe le pouvoir de police des maires
il y a un sénateur UMP pilé un autre
socialiste votre serviteur qui récemment
en présence de Monsieur Vals sur la
question des polices municipales et
cetera on on fait la démonstration
preuve à l'appui citation à l'appui
questionnaire à l'appui que des maires
faisaient dans ce qu'on appelle par
ailleurs la mutualisation faisait des
progrès dans le champ de
l'intercommunalité sans pour autant se
désaisir une seule seconde de l'exercice
du pouvoir de de police de merdes donc
on peut penser que vous visez un un vrai
problème parce que je suppose que vous
êtes tombé dans ce texte vous avez vu
tout le tout le les paragraphes qui
concerne pouvoir de police spécial et
cetera votre sang n'a fait qu'un tour
hein euh mais je pense quand même que on
peut on peut approfondir les choses ce
qu'il faut se dire aux uns et aux autres
et moi je partage hein je pense que
c'est un beau projet il faut y aller il
faut le travailler il a probablement
être travaillé euh il ne sera il ne peut
passer il ne peut passer peut-être avec
plusieurs lectures il ne peut passer que
si effectivement on donne aussi dans ce
texte des éléments que Madame gourou et
et d'autres sénateurs bien plus
expérimentés que moi avait
déjà rappelé dans des documents
antérieurs hein si on donne quand même
dès ce texte quand même un certain
nombre de points de repère qui se font
cruellement défaut sur les
départements qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
devenir comment ils vont se positionner
l'exercice
également dans la perspective d'une
élection suffrage universel direct hein
qui
est quasi inscrite dans le ciel
qu'est-ce qui reste de l'autonomie
communale qu'est-ce qui reste quand on
est titulaire d'une compétence dans
unepci des conditions dans lesquelles on
on on met en place la mutualisation
c'est tout ça qu'ensemble finalement
dans les deux tables rondes vous posez
c'est donc là-dessus que patiemment et
probablement avec beaucoup de coup à
prendre mais patiemment on va essayer de
travailler quoi voilà merci merci René
Viren donc je demande à mes collègues
qui veut
s'exprimer madame gourau présidente de
la délégation sénatoriale au
collectivité locale et à la
décentralisation bah i tu
veux
merci cher président simplement François
Nuel buffet qui a dû partir pour une
autre réunion m'a
chargé de de l'excuser de ne pas pouvoir
rester jusqu'à l'issue de cette
réunion il a souhaité aussi que nous
rappelions que nous étions allés
récemment à Lyon justement la délégation
aux collectivités territoriales que nous
avons eu une journée très intéressante
que naturellement Gérard Colomb Michel
Mercier nous ont organiser une réunion
de travail le matin avec tous les
membres de la communauté urbaine des
maires enfin bon des conseillers
généraux madame la Présidente était là
c'était tout à fait intéressant et puis
nous avons vu Jean-Jacques Keran donc le
président de la Région l'après-midi nous
avons rencontré le préfet exa également
alors évidemment je ne vais pas revenir
sur ce que vous venez de redire
simplement quand on vous écoute tous on
sent déjà je dirais un un projet je ne
dirais pas abouti puisque tu viens de
dire qu'il y a un certain nombre de
choses sur lesquelles il faut revenir
René mais on sent bien que le projet a
été déjà mûement
réfléchi construit aussi bien
dans ses côtés positifs et et donc ça sa
mise en place que les réserves que les
uns et les autres ont pu
affirmer ici ou là il y a deux choses
qui m'apparaissent comme évidentes c'est
à la fois bon effectivement comment
l'action économique se partage-t-elle
avec la région c'est là un une des
questions centrale et puis deuxièmement
ce que j'ai ressenti sur le terrain
beaucoup c'est euh
quel rôle les communes gardent--ell dans
cet ensemble moi c'est les deux sujets
qui me semble pour essayer de faire une
synthèse c'est les deux sujets qui me
semblent prédominants et sur lesquels il
faut je crois apporter une réponse dans
le travail législatif merci merci Madame
Gour vous me permettrez d'ajouter trois
petites
questions premièrement j'ai reçu le
président du conseil général de Loire
Atlantique qui est extrêmement remonté
et qui m'a dit vraiment nous moi en tant
que président de conseil général je
n'accepte pas ça je suis d'accord pour
qu'il y ait des conventions entre le
département et la métropole mais pas que
la loi je suis pas d'accord avec le fait
que la loi envoie comme ça par la loi
les compétences du département dans la
métropole bon voilà qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette réaction de ce président
qui est venu nous voir 2è petite
question ce matin nous avons reçu avec
messieurs les rapporteurs je salue
Claude dylain qui est revenu après avoir
été dans une réunion où il a été nommé
rapporteur c'est quand même important
qu'il qu' qu'il soit allé euh madame la
présidente d'une importante communauté
urbaine de France du vers le nord
monsieur vir donc qui nous a dit euh et
bien moi je pense que la Métro ou la la
communauté urbaine devenue métropole ne
doit pas s'occuper du social
elle doit s'occuper de tout ce qui est
stratégique économique développement et
autant je trouve que le département peut
confier à la commune échelon de
proximité des responsabilités sociales
autant je pense que la métropole doit
rester dans des dimensions qui sont des
dimensions stratégiques donc je dis pas
du tout que je partage mais j'ai entendu
ça ce matin donc je me suis dit dans le
fond peut-être que je pourrais poser une
question et puis j'ai une troisème
petite question si la loi est est votée
telle qu'elle est par exemple pour Lyon
mais je présente les excuses pour nos
amis de Marseille et des bouches du rô
et de he et des autres lieux du du bouch
du rô parce que nous avons pris un peu
de retard mais dans le fond chacun on
avait déjà pris du retard avec Paris
c'est eux qui maintenant qu'ils sont
partis on peut dire que c'est eux les
responsables du retard mais enfin chacun
peut entendre ce qui se passe ailleurs
c'est aussi intéressant donc si très
très franchement hein si vous avez une
collectivité dans laquelle vous avez
toutes les compétences d'une communauté
urbaine plus toutes les compétences du
département est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas qu'il faudrait que les électeurs
désignent directement le Conseil non
mais directement même pas le fléchage
c'est-à-dire qu'un vote quoi oui quand
même poser cette question parce que
regardez si on a que les responsabilités
du département que ce soit binominal ou
pas binominal les gens votent donc je
pose cette troisième petite question
s'il y a pas d'autres questions je vais
redonner de manière finale mes chers
amis des bouches du rô la parole à nos
amis du rô en commençant par l'ordre
inverse et en vous demandant l'exercice
suivant qui est très difficile c'est de
faire une synthèse percutante de ce que
vous avez envie de dire au terme du
débat alors Monsieur le Député oui merci
monsieur le Président percutante je sais
pas tout simplement vous dire que je
crois que c'est une belle
expérimentation qui qui qui va avoir
lieu pour le rô et pour le Lyon je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui est excitant
par d'excitation parce que c'est vrai
que c'est c'est tout nouveau vous avez
posé des questions liées notamment
au à l'avenir de de cette métropole moi
je pense qu'une métropole doit exercer
les compétences pleines et entières du
département comme le prévoit pour la
métropole lyonnaise sinon franchement il
y a aucun intérêt de de créer une
métropole se méfier quand même parce que
c'est un mal bien français de vouloir
des métropoles de partout parce que au
bout d'un moment il y aura plus de
signification à l'échelle européenne
donc méfions-nous on l'a vu avec les
pôle de compétitivité on est tous pareil
hein moi en tant que parlementaire on
essaie tous mais au bout d'un moment ça
veut plus rien dire donc de vraies
métropoles à l'échelon euré avec des
vraies compétences et l'avenir je crois
au niveau des l'élection
direct bien sûr ça sera le cas à
l'avenir je vois pas comment il peut en
être autrement si les élus veulent pas
ce sont les contribuob qu'il demanderont
voilà merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le le député Monsieur l'Adjoint
au Maire de Lon et Monsieur le Maire de
La Croix Rousse merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur président jeais
simplement d'abord d'abord peut-être une
conclusion en forme d'exemple parce que
c'est c'est bien de pouvoir toucher du
doigt ce que ça va ce que ça va procurer
je donnerai simplement un exemple le
grand lon est
aujourd'hui est déjà depuis quelques
années tête de pont pour tout ce qui
tourne autour de la solidarité urbaine
et du renouvellement urbain on a refait
on a reconstitué d'ailleurs avec nos
partenaires et y compris avec la région
un certain nombre de quartiers de nos
banlieux je pense notamment à
vaauenvelin on a fait de la rénovation
on a fait de la solidarité urbaine
demain avec les compétences euh du
conseil général dans dans dans la
métropole on va y mettre toute cette
cohérence de la cohésion sociale et et
quelque part c'est en résumé ce que l'on
peut ce que l'on peut faire on voit bien
à travers on l'a pas listé les
politiques publiques du Grand lon et du
conseil général mais on voit bien les
les les passerell les passerelles
évidentes on a parlé on a parlé de
l'économie de l'autre côté on a l'emploi
et l'insertion on voit bien évidemment
qu'il y a là bien à gagner à être
beaucoup plus cohérent sur ces sur ces
différentes politiques là donc moi je
Dir en conclusion ce que nous voulons ce
que je disais finalement l'introduction
parce que
on on est on redonne un peu toujours les
mêmes messages mais c'est cette
compétitivité et cette cohésion sociale
bien évidemment avec un exercice
démocratique qui doit aller jusqu'au
bout c'est-à-dire que à terme et vous
avez posé la question monsieur le
Président bien évidemment il faudra qu'à
un moment ou un autre en l'occurrence si
j'ai bien compris c'est plutôt 2020 les
conseillers soient désignés au suffrage
universel direct la loi aujourd'hui
comment comment peut-on comment
pourrait-onur comment pourrait-on
s'affranchir de ça comment pourrait-on
s'affranchir de ça par rapport à nos
citoyens alors que je je je reviens je
reviens monsieur le Président vous
posiez une question aussi sur le Conseil
Général de on disait on pourrait faire
de la convention moi je voudrais en
conclusion
aussi ouais mais moi je voudrais
simplement rendre hommage au au tout à
l'heure quelqu'un dit l'annonce s'est
fait un peu de manière abrut et de
manière un peu soudaine mais moi je je
remercie et le président du conseil
général et le président du Grand Lon qui
ont pris quelque part ce risque de entre
guillemets renverser la table pour
pouvoir faire une proposition de cette
importance là qui ensuite a été bien
évidemment très bien je crois relayé je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ça fait l'objet
d'une loi et moi je m'en je m'en
félicite et je crois que c'est un un
courage un
courage de et un exercice de démocratie
qui peut paraître un peu paradoxal dans
un premier temps parce que c'est le
fruit d'une annonce qui était non pas
une surprise parce que je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure dans les premiers discours de
Gérard colon évoquait déjà cette
métropole on a eu un certain nombre de
de présence de sénateurs et de
commissions qui sont venus nous
rencontrer sur sur le territoire on n
jamais caché cette volonté là et et et
Michel Mercier non plus et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui moi ce que je voudrais
dire en conclusion c'est cette c'est
c'est nous sommes très très heureux de
pouvoir euh le plus rapidement possible
voir cette loi s'appliquer sur notre
territoire avec bien évidemment un
certain nombre de de d'améliorations et
de modifications tes qu'elles ont été
formulé et et en particulier et
notamment par Jean-Paul Bret autour des
communes sur le pouvoir de police au
passage euh qu'on soit bien clair
euh
Gérard colonb ne souhaite n'a pas
souhaité lui il se trouve que dans la
loi mais j'ai compris qu'il y avait un
problème juridique me semble-t-il et que
c'est plus simple à énoncer qu'à
réaliser de séparer ces pouvoirs de
police que des sujets qui sont attachés
au pouvoirs de police nétant pas juris
je m'arrêterai là en tout cas on on ne
réclame pas en tout cas on ne revendique
pas et la métropole ne revendique pas
l'ensemble des pouvoirs des pouvoirs de
police sur les sur les étapes pardon sur
ce qui ce qui tourne autour de ce qu'on
appelle des établissements d'intérêt
métropolitains je crois que très
clairement on est plus mais ça reste à
définir Jean-Paul bretlad c'est
peut-être qu'est-ce qu'on considère
comme établissement d'intérêt
métropolitain je crois pas que
l'objectif ça soit demain matin d'aller
intégrer puisquon a évoqué on a évoqué
le TNP que tout le monde connaît euh
dans dans dans le dans le comment dire
dans la métropole je crois pas que c'est
ça l'objectif mais la question peut se
poser à un moment donné d'établissement
d'intérêt métropolitain je crois qu'il
faut rien s'interdire làdusoui mais le
TNP restera à villeurbane le TNP restera
à villeorbane comme l'astrobal reste à
villeorbane comme les canus resteront
laous on sait très bien merci alors
merci Monsieur l'Adjoint c'était pas la
peine de faire la pub de Monsieur
Mercier et colon car ce sont deux
collègues que nous connaissons bien N
nous connaissons tout leur tout le
toutes leur qualités alors Monsieur le
Maire de villeorbaneci
oui je crois que les propos de chacun
ici ne sont pas dans dans une remise en
cause des objectifs initiaux de la
démarche on l'a tous dit en préambule
avec plus ou moins de
force et même de l'évolution d'une d'un
EPCI vers une collectivité locale même
si ça pose à l'évidence quand même
beaucoup de problèmes mais il me semble
que ce que la loi doit éviter c'est ce
que
la ce que la loi doit éviter éviter
pardon c'est le principe d'une elle doit
laisser aux collectivités et aux
communes en particulier la métropole la
possibilité d'une d'une
auto-organisation on le VO collègue de
Marseille me semble-t-il
du R également Bou
du bouches du R
du jamais nulle part très vite alors oui
voilà je crois qu'il faut que
aujourd'hui il faut veiller à ce qu'
relève vraiment de la loi dans ce qu' a
de normative dans l'organisation et il
faut laisser la possibilité dans un
cadre certains l'ont dit tout à l'heure
qui va demander du temps d'évoluer et
cette évolution elle doit être laissée
d'une certaine manière à la enfin à à
l'organisation des communes au sein de
la métropole et de la métropole avec les
communes il faut pas en gros que le
cadre au départ soit un cadre qui soit
normatif je reprends alors puisqu'on a
cité beaucoup l'exemple des équipements
culturels l'intérêt métropolitain
d'abord il va falloir dire ce que c'est
que l'intérêt métropolitain quand il va
falloir le fixer législativement ça va
pas être facile donc il faut admettre ce
principe d'une mutualisation de
travailler ensemble mais il faut laisser
ensuite dans le cadre de la métropole la
possibilité aux communes et la métropole
de se mettre d'accord pour voir comment
elles vut vont mettre en place ce genre
de chose et ne pas l'indiquer d'une
manière normative au niveau de la loi je
crois que c'est ça alors c'est un espèce
de principe qu'il faut tenir ça signifie
qu'il faut que la loi je pense sur
d'articles les réécrive en ouvrant les
possibilités en indiquant peut-être vers
ce à quoi ça peut conduire mais en ne le
mettant pas dès le départ sinon on va
aller à de vrais
conflits voilà bon merci de de merci de
le dire finalement mieux que moi voilà
merci
Monsieur le Maire hein elle ouvre la
possibilité non vous pouvez continuer la
phrase Monsieur le Maire non elle ouvre
la possibilité de mais en même temps
elle laisse aux acteurs des la commune
et la métropole la façon de s'organiser
dans ce cadre-là c'est c'est là qu'on
tient un petit peu l'essentiel merci
madame la Présidente moi simplement je
dois dire que notre expérience est assez
particulière puisque elle émane de
Gérard coland et Michel Mercier qui sont
d'horizon politique on va dire pas très
éloigné mais malgré tout différent et
que c'est peut-être grâce à cela que
c'est peut-être grâce à cela en
particulier que nous avons un
consensus c'est pour cela sans doute que
nous avons un consensus aussi fort sur
le département ce qui facilite
grandement les choses est-ce que ce sera
vrai dans toutes les métropoles c'est
peut-être pas si évident que ça et
d'autre part je pense que si l'ex notre
expérience est probante alors peut-être
effectivement S traînera d'autres mais
on est quand même dans un cas
particulier assez intéressant la
deuxième question que vous avez posé
posé sur les délégations aux communes je
redis mon inquiétude sur enfin disons le
le fait qu'il est vraiment très très
important que ce soit dans un cadre bien
précis si on veut garder cette équité
sur l'ensemble du territoire sur
l'ensemble de la métropole je crois que
ça c'est c'est vraiment important je dis
que un RSA une personne au RSA dans un
quartier riche
doit avoir le même traitement qu'une
personne RA dans un quartier pauvre et
ça c'est quelque chose qui doit être
vraiment intégré voilà sur ces deux
questions je ce que
je merci madame la Présidente enfin pour
finir deux deux derniers orateur
monsieur le Président de la Région
ronalpe merci monsieur le président
ayant été ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement je pense que la sagesse du
Sénat permettra d'éviter qu'on fasse une
loi encore plus bavarde que celle qui
nous proposé parce que vraiment on dit
qu'en matière de de collectivité
territoriale on rentre avec 120 articles
on sort avec 240 j'espère que rentrant
avec certain nombre d'articles on
sortira avec moi par c'est pas la peine
de redire il y a des principes de libre
administration c'est c'est un travail
monsieur le rapporteur un peu de
nettoyage qui est à faire bon je crois
qu'on est pour répondre aux questions de
de Monsieur S
oui le transfert peut se faire par
convention là on est quand même dans un
niveau
d'intégration qui qui est quand même
supérieur à la Convention puisque là
c'est le département qui disparaît en
tant que collectivité territoriale sur
le territoire de la métropole il faut il
faut saluer donc ce qui ce qui se passe
dans la simplification je l'ai déjà dit
après sur exercice du social je crois
qu'il faut un peu laisser se dérouler
les choses et il peut y avoir ici une
répartition avec les communes sur le le
statut
cache pas que je suis interrogatif
est-ce qu'on peut créer une collectivité
territoriale de l'article 72 un statut
spécial avec une élection au 3e degré
c'est une sacrée interrogation
l'élection au suffrage universel
s'imposera elle s'imposera dès 2020
alors ça peut être il faut je crois
qu'il faut le dire clairement parce ça
peut être une période temporaire vous
verrez ce que dira le Conseil
constitutionnel
mais bon il y a les fait qui essayent de
passer des couches de hydrophile pour
çaasse mal bon enfin la question est
posée dernier point pour vous
caractériser la région ronalpe moi je
donnerai trois chiffres la région
ronalpe est la 6e région européenne par
son PIB la ville de Lyon la le grand lon
pardon le grand Lion et la 21e
communauté de métropole par son PIB et
l'aéroport de Lyon est le 47e vous voyez
que voilà un peu les
défis merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Michel Mercier merci monsieur
le Président juste quelques mots d'abord
je suis persuadé
qu'aujourd'hui l'unité de la République
n'est pas renforcé par l'uniformité au
contraire et qu'il faut tenir compte des
spécificités des situations
géographiques ou autres le modèle
lyonnais c'est pas un modèle il est
propre à Lyon et on veut pas l'imposer à
qui que ce soit parce que la situation
géographique historique politique chez
nous il y a une tradition de de
modérantisme qui se retrouve aussi bien
dans une part importante du Parti
socialiste et des partis de droite et du
centre qui vivent ensemble cette
situation au moins depuis la Libération
donc c'est un système particulier et
c'est pas for on demande pas d'exporter
on demande et ça l'expérimentation de
nous laisser aller au bout de notre
proposition c'est ce qu'on attend du
Parlement ça c'est le premier point j'ai
bien compris les trois questions que que
nous a posé le président
sueur transférer par
convention probablement Loire Atlantique
mais c'est pas notre problème la
situation est
différente c'est vrai que c'est moi qui
l'ai fait j'aurais pu
refuser de faire disparaître les
département sur le territoire de la
Communauté urbaine et on n'urait pas de
métropole et je crois qu'on aurait
manqué une occasion c'est il faut bien
aussi que l'on bouge dans le monde des
collectivités territoriales on ne peut
pas dire que tout est beau et que l'âge
d'Ur c'est maintenant on sait que c'est
faux donc il faut accepter quand c'est
possible des changement ils sont pas
forcément les mêmes partout dire que la
métropole ne doit pas traiter social moi
je pense que c'est faux parce que on
peut pas aller en Chine à Dubaï dans les
émirats Arab Unis en Amérique du Sud
vendre des grands projets il faut le
faire mais il faut le faire en sachant
qui est sur le territoire qui il faut
sortir de la misère et pourquoi on va
aller vendre ces projets pas pour faire
beau mais pour aider ceux qui sont
exclus et qui deviendront demain des
agents du progrès je crois que c'est au
contraire très important que les élus de
la métropole de demain apprennent
apprennent parce qu'il faud apprendre
les métiers du
social l'idée que l'on
pourrait faire éclater l'exercice de ces
compétences sociales dans les communes
certaines c'est vrai et je reconnais que
pour la PMI ça peut être exact sûrement
pas pour le RSA sûrement pas pour les
personnes à jeux déépendante sûrement
pas euh pour les personnes handicapées
parce que c'est pas possible puis
faudrait quand même pas croire et que
sur le territoire de la Communauté
Urbaine de Lyon il y a que des communes
de plus de 150000 habitants il y en a
aussi qui ont moins de 1000 habitants
donc c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
bah il y en a autant qui ont moins de
1000 habitants que communes qui ont plus
de
150000 c'està dire une une il y en a une
moins de 1000 et une de plus de 150000
donc
égalité et c'est cette diversité là qui
permet pas des solutions toutes faites
je dois dire pour monsieur le rapporteur
que sur le pouvoir de police moi je suis
assez
d'accord c'est mal ficelé pour l'instant
mais qu'il faut faire très attention
parce que il faudrait pas sortir de la
métropole et laisser dans les
communautés de communes qui sont la la
formule la moins intégrée de coopération
intercommunale aujourd'hui où il y a le
transfert du pouvoir de police également
pour les
taxisi pour les taxis moi je je suis en
train de faire une commité de commune
50000 habitants nouvelles après avoir
fait une commune nouvelle un département
nouveau il faut que ça change euh j'ai
cru que c'était l'ordre le mot l'ordre
du jour donc je l'applique même si j'en
vois qui ont plus de difficultés à
l'appliquer que moi mais je vois pas
comment on pourrait mettre la police de
taxis euh dans une zone rurale et puis
pas la mettre dans la métropole je pense
qu'il faut la mettre la laisser au MRE
dans tous les cas et que l'affaire se
règlera euh comme cela quand euh à
l'élection du Conseil métropolitain bah
tout le monde sait bien et que dans
toute loi il y a des
habiletés sinon ça marche pas et
l'habilité dans la loi pour Lyon c'est
de dire que la métropole bien on la
créera après l'élection municipale de
2014 et j'ajoute Messieurs les
Présidents rapporteurs après les
élections sénatorial de septembre 2014
puisqu'il n'a échappé ni au président ni
au rapporteur que texte de loi allit
d'ici ces élections modifier le corp
électoral sénatorial pour garantir le
résultat à condition dans drone bien
entendu qu'on garde le département
actuel pour faire l'élection sénatoriale
on n'est pas tombé de la dernière pluie
on est pas complètement naïf
mais puisqueon doit dire les choses on
les dit bien et finir finir de le dire
et tiens et donc moi je dis très
clairement que en 2014 il y il aura une
élection par fléchage on peut arguer que
c'est quand même une élection directe
mais c'est quand même un peu artificiel
et qu'en 2020 on aura une élection au
suffrage direct pour l'élection du
conseil communautaire sinon sinon on
perdra ce qui est l'essentiel du projet
lyonnais qui est d'avoir une
collectivité territoriale de la
République même à titre dérogatoire il
faudra qu' son conseil soit élu au
suffrage direct mais je le redis pour
finir c'est cela répond à une situation
particulière et c'est pas
obligatoirement exportable partout
ailleurs et si la région rondalpe
dernier mot peut avoir des difficultés
et craindre la métropole mon cher
Jean-Jacques les métropo oui c'est pas
la métropole Deon qu'il faut que tu
craignes c'est parce que tu as laissé
faire euh les pôles non non faut quand
même m'entendre jusqu'au bout c'est
parce que tu as laissé faire les pôles
métropolitains bon alors et qu'on va se
trouver avec introduction oui ou oui on
va se trouver avec une métropole un pôle
métropolitain à Lyon une métropole à
Grenoble un pô métropolitain dans jeu de
voie
français j'avais demander une réponse
percutante de ce point de vue-l nous
sommes servis mais je crois que de
Monsieur Michel Mercier fait rebondir le
débat or le débat doit rebondir vers
Marseille maintenant c'est l'heure alors
on remercie tous nos amis de du rô et de
l'agglomération lyonnaise et on demande
à tous nos amis de Marseille et d'ex en
Provence et autres communauté du bouge
du rô de venir mes chers collègues nous
sommes vraiment heureux de vous saluer
tous et toutes je dois vous dire
que c'est un grand plaisir après avoir
fait une première table ronde sur Paris
une deuxième sur Lyon d'arriver en plus
ça va plus on avance vers le soleil vers
la mer Méditerranée qui nous échè et
vers votre beau département alors euh
premièrement une délégation importante
tout ce que vous allez dire sera dans le
rapport hein donc toutes vos paroles
seront
inscrites deuxièmement je vous présente
les
rapporteurs qui sont tous les deux là
fidèles au poste donc rapporteur pour la
commission des lois René Vandy redonct
qui est de l'autre côté de la France
mais vous savez bien que il y a qu'une
seule France il était maire de roubé et
il est vice-président de la Communauté
urbaine de l'île roubé tourcoin donc il
connaît un peu le sujet surtout il a le
sens du
dialogue rapporteur pour la commission
des affaires économiques Claude dylin
qui comme vous le savez est un grand
spécialiste des questions urbaines qui a
été maire d'une des villes où il y a le
plus de difficultés en France
hein et puis euh
Madame Jacqueline gourau qui est avec
nous qui est présidente de la la
délégation sénatoriale aux collectivités
locales et à la
décentralisation alors on va tous vous
donner la parole pendant environ 5
minutes euh j'ai tenu et je le dis je
prends ma responsabilité he
bon on est là pour ça à ce qu'il y ait
plusieurs points de vue représentés
parce que si on est là pour entendre un
son de cloche je dis pas que on n pas
des cloches mais il faut qu'il y ait
tous les sons tout les sensibilités et
ce que j'ai dit ce matin parce que j'ai
eu l'honneur le matin de parler dans
francebleleu Provence donc ça m'a fait
beaucoup d'honneur je le redis il y a un
projet de loi ce projet de loi c'est un
projet et la loi et bien elle arrivera
dans un certain nombre de mois quand ça
aurait été modifié par le Sénat
remodifié par l'Assemblée nationale et
je salue nos amis députés qui sont ici
présent avec nous remodifié par le Sénat
remodifié par l'Assemblée nationale donc
nous on comprend bien qu'il y a
plusieurs points de vue et on comprend
bien aussi ce que vous êtes déjà un
certain nombre d'entrevu venu nous dire
et on n'est pas là pour pour adopter
comme ça un texte qui a été préparé je
parle devant mes mes collègues hein qui
sont venus vous écouter de toute la
France hein de tous les divers
départements nous sommes là pour faire
la loi alors j'ai une petite tuile qui
est arrivée
c'est que le président du Sénat m'a
convoqué pour une réunion que j'espère
très courte de la Conférence des
présidents à
18h30 c'est pourquoi madame Sophie
joissin que vous connaissez et qui est
vice-présidente de la Commission des
lois je sais pas si vous saviez cela
elle présidera pendant le quelques
minutes où je devrais partir bon ce sera
quelqu'un du bouche dururô qui
présidera bon alors bon il faut pas dire
que c'est un point de vue plutôt qu'un
autre quand on préside au Sénat de toute
façon n pas le droit de dire son point
de vue on préside bien alors on va vous
je sais que certains on va prendre
peut-être dans l'ordre je sais pas c'est
arbitraire mais et et Eugène je crois
que tu dois repartir là-bas hein donc on
peut peut-être commencer par toi prendre
tout le monde dans l'ordre et demander à
chacun de parler 5 minutes maximum parce
que ça va nous permettre une bonne
expression donc nous commençons par
Eugène
Caselli qui est comme vous le savez
président de la Communauté Urbaine
Marseille-Provence métropole
Eugène merci monsieur le Président je
vais essayer d'être concis en 5 minutes
dans
un un sujet qui mériterait de très long
développement bien je vais essayer de
m'entenir aux grandes idées aujourd'hui
le fait urbain est
incontestable en Europe dans le monde
c'est autour des grands centres urbains
que se créent desésor for les richesses
et les
développements d'autre part ces grands
centres urbains sont en compétition sont
chez nous en Europe du Sud ils le sont
en Méditerranée ils le sont aussi au
nord de l'Europe donc nous sommes dans
la compétition des territoire et si on n
pas ça je dirais dans l'idée je crois
qu'on peut pas aller plus loin dans le
débat nous avons un territoire chez nous
qui est un territoire à très fort
potentiel mais un potentiel qui n'est
pas u diser parce que ce prentiel est
balcanisé en un certain nombre
d'intercommunalités ces
intercommunalités ont toutes des forces
en toutes des faiblesses bien entendu
mais si on regroupe nos forces autour
d'un projet commun je crois qu'on peut
peser très lourd en Europe du Sud et en
Méditerranée pour vous donner une idée
si on balaye un petit peu le territoire
très rapidement on a le grand projet
itire qui est un projet à 30 ans qui est
un projet de de de de très grand à venir
on a bien le trisème port pétrolier du
monde chez nous à fosse on a le premier
port anpronde de Méditerranée le premier
port de Méditerranée premier port
commercial qui est celui de Marseille ou
n'importe quel type de bateau dans le
monde peut venir mouiller à Marseille
c'est un des aéroports qui peut accepter
la totalité de tous les bateaux du monde
donc c'est une très grande force euh
nous avons toute l'industrie
pétrochimique nous avons les
fininerie nous avons des CHU de première
importance autour de Marseille de niveau
européen les 2è après ce de Paris la
fusion des universités ex-marseille nous
sommes devenus la première université de
France et la 20e d'Europe à en devenir
quasi immédiat
euh nous avons un aéroport international
celui de Marseille de grandes gares
multimodales l'une à Marseille l'autre
AEX nous avons des pôles de rocher se
pôles de compétitivité
nous avons les sciences du vivant à
l'université de lumini au sud de
Marseille et au nord nous avons les
sciences de l'ingénieur avec le pôle de
Château Gombert le Parc national des
Calanques donc nous avons d'énormes
potentialités à faire jouer une ville
centre de cette métropole future qui est
Marseille qui est la 2è ville de France
au niveau démographique avec 860000
habitants un bassin d'emploi quand même
qui est très important donc de très
grandes forces mais ce territoire n'a
pas de projet commun il est balcanisé au
niveau des transports sur le territoire
des BCH du rô il y a 10 autorités
organisatrices de
transport sur les six intercommunalités
dont dont on parle il y a six euh
autorités organisatrices de
transport au niveau de l'économie il y
a une balcanisation des des des zones
d'activité et et une une balcanisation
également des zones des zones
commerciales euh au niveau du logement
il n'y a pas de SCOT commun bien entendu
donc il y a pas d'unité du territoire
tout cela n'est pas fait pour n faire
avancer au contraire sont des outils de
retardement Marseille elle a toutes les
grandes fonctions urbaineson connaî
aéroport g multimodal CHU université et
ce et
ce effectivement Marseille et je dirais
la ville principale mais le projet
commun de territoire do pas être un
projet marseillais ça doit être un
projet fédérateur un projet de toutes
les intercommunalités pour pouvoir peser
dans la compétition des territoires en
ayant un projet commun qui fasse de nous
un pôle puissant en Europe du Sud et en
Méditerranée aujourd'hui nous avons gne
comme concurrent nous avons Barcelone
bien sûr qui a pris beaucoup d'avance G
qui est quasiment sur la même ligne que
nous aujourd'hui mais qui est en passe
une drite à nous avons Trieste don nous
ne pouvons pas je dirais faire
l'économie de nous
rassembler
la métropole doit s'occuper de quoi doit
s'occuper effectivement que des
fonctions égaliennes c'est-à-dire les
transports le développement économique
la recherche l'innovation
l'environnement le logement et le schéma
de cohérence territoriale c'est ça la
métropole
c'est c'est une assemblée qui va gérer
les grandes fonctions du territoire tout
le reste toute la proximité doit être
laissé au mairies les mairies qui
doivent garder bien entendu leur
fiscalité propre tout les fonctions de
proximité euh les dotations d'État et
les dotations actuelles qui leur sont
données par les agglomérations qui
doivent être transposé en dotation
métropolitaine il doit y avoir bien sûr
sur la métropole une fiscalité
métropolitaine commune mais elle doit
être lissée bien entendu sur un nombre
dranné suffisant pour que ça ne soit pas
euh je dirais de très douloureux et très
difficile au départ donc je je pense que
une période de 10 ans semble nécessaire
pour 10 LC la fiscalité métropolitaine
c'est-à-dire celle des aglos euh pour
arriver à une uniformisation euh de ces
fiscalité là voilà en gros pourquoi moi
je défends le projet de métropole je
crois que ce projet il est bon pour le
territoire il est bon pour Marseille
bien entendu Marseille qui génère aussi
des zones de pauvreté parce que c'est un
port et historiquement c'est là euh que
l'immigration arrive et c'est là que
l'immigration reste mais ce que je dis
et je le dis depuis maintenant plusieurs
années si l'on y prend garde la pauvreté
marseillaise va déborder sur les autres
intercommunalités voisines on ne peut
plus rester dans une situation où
Marseille prisonnière de son corser
montagneux en ayant toutes les charges
de centralité pourra rester ainsi très
longtemps sans aller vers un déclin
programmé donc c'est un projet de
territoire qui doit profiter à tous
chacun doit y avoir sa place bien
entendu c'est un projet euh qui doit
maintenant passer une véritable phase de
discussion parce que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
personne ne sait parl et je crois que
maintenant nous arrivons à une échéance
qui est l'échéance de la loi va bien
falloir qu'on se mette autour d'une
table et qu'on discute vraiment de ces
problématiques là parce qu'elles sont
nécessaires pour le développement pas
simplement je le dis de la ville de
Marseille mais de l'ensemble du
territoire bien merci monsieur le
Président je remercie Eugène gazelli et
je donne la parole à Madame Marie
joissin qui est maire d'ex en Provence
monsieur monsieur le Président come on
se parle beaucoup depuis plus de plus de
2 ans et depuis un certain nombre de
mois on s'est réparti la tâche et on
vous a donné une liste qui est évolutive
en fonction de ce que nous avons à
défendre les uns et les autres alors si
ça vous dérange pas monsieur le
Président de nous appeler en fonction de
cette liste parce que c'est une
chronologie que nous avons estimé
logique vous nous dira après alors dans
la liste qui m'a été confiée puis après
on donnera la parole à Monsieur Menucci
comme ça la liste sera bien encadré on
peut dire ça bon ça marche alors
premièrement monsieur George Christiani
maire de M représentant de l'Union des
Maires des bouches du rô monsieur
Christiani qui est déjà venu nous
parler oui c'est exact monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs messieurs les rapporteurs euh
ce texte qui émane de la
DGCL est un texte ancien il a été
présenté le 16 décembre 2010 à
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est vrai
qu'il est passé à une très courte
majorité au
Sénat je me souviens d'ailleurs euh un
un sénateur de grande envergure qui
était assez gêné voire embarrassé
lorsqu'il nous avait avit présenté ce
dossier il était de la majorité
précédente peut-être avait-il déjà
imaginé ou penser à une alternance
possible à cause de ce texte donc on
était dans ce sujet-là lorsqu'on nous
avait présenté la réforme territoriale
donc il est bon de se rendre compte
qu'il y a quelques élus et notamment
marseillais qui
était très opposé voire virulent à cette
loi de la réforme territoriale
de 2010 instituant les métropoles il ne
faut pas l'oublier et aujourd'hui sont
devenus des ardents défenseurs donc un
humble maire de terrain comme je
suis je constate que au niveau de la de
de l'Association des maires de France
notamment du vice-président monsieur
ligel ou son président Monsieur
Pélissard il y a une cohérence au niveau
de leur approche de la loi ils étaient
très très inquiets de la de la réforme
territoriale ils le sont toujours
aujourd'hui et il y a eu aussi des
députés et des sénateurs qui étaient
opposés bien qu'ils étaient de la
majorité antérieur par exemple je pense
à ma voisine madame joissin qui s'est
opposée à à cette loi mais il y en a
d'autres il y a aussi jean-noë Guerini
qui s'est opposé qui est toujours opposé
madame joissin également Bernard res
pourquoi pas il y en a bien d'autres
donc il y a quelque part des
parlementaires qui sont très cohérents
ils étaient opposés à la réforme
territoriale et ils sont aujourd'hui
opposés à une réforme qui est il faut
bien l'avouer très très très similaire
et dans dans certains articles qui sont
identique donc il faut quand même se
poser cette
question pourquoi
euh une majorité d'une de la Haute
Assemblée à un à un moment
donné bascule et pourquoi aujourd'hui on
est dans cette situation un peu délicate
pour nous maire et maire des bouches du
rô car on est quand même on est quand
même dans une situation où on n'est pas
loin de certaines propositions de cette
loi mais on est fort éloigné d'autres on
est proche pour les transports pour le
développement
économique mais on est très éloigné en
ce qui concerne le PLU en ce qui
concerne l'aménagement de voirie en ce
qui concerne une 14 compétences 14
compétences définitivement transféré
dans une
métropole et ça c'est quelque chose pour
nous qui a cristallisé 109 mè
sur
119 109 mèes sur 119 dont 12 de la
communauté urbaine de Marseille sur les
18 donc c'est bien qu'il y a quelque
part dans les Bouches du
rô quelque chose qui s'est passé car se
retrouver dans une unanimité une quasi
unanimité 109/ 119 12 de la communauté
urbaine sur les 18 se retrouver dans
cette dans cette démarche qui consiste à
dire on va proposer autre chose plutôt
que d'accepter ce qu'on nous impose je
pense que c'est quand même une une
capacité de 109 mères à ne pas perdre le
Nord républicain et je crois qu'il faut
euh vraiment s'en rendre compte il y a
vraiment une raison donc cette raison là
nous sommes ici pour essayer de vous la
présenter mais pour surtout pour essayer
de vous dire que lorsqu'on lit l'étude
d'impact qui a été qui a été joint à ce
projet de loi et notamment la page 49
50 et 51 on se demande vraiment comment
peut-on écrire des mots aussi
extravagants comment peut-on oser dire
que l'on connaît parfaitement un
territoire lorsqu'on écrit des mots
pareils des mots attrayants certes
certes c'est attrayant le fait urbain on
ne le ni pas la métropole non plus
l'aire métropolitaine on ne la ni pas
mais il faut quand même pas oublier que
c'est un un département qui est
également périurbain qui est également
rural donc le fait urbain je suis bien
d'accord mais ce n'est pas ça les
BOUCHES DU Ron donc lorsqu'on lit ce ce
travail là on se dit que peut-être
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
allez être fourvoyés voir faussés dans
vos jugements donc c'est pour ça que
nous sommes là et on vous en remercie
mais on pense que c'est un texte un
texte en tout cas pour les BOUCHES DU rô
qui est un texte à risque démocratique
dans la mesure où ça va éloigner et ça
va gaspiller la capacité des maires à
recueillir 80 % des électeurs ça va
gaspiller cette chance que nous avons
dans en France de pouvoir exprimer sur
les élus locaux les élus municipaux 80
personnes qui viennent aux urnes et ça
on pense que c'est une erreur que de
créer parce que que c'est bien ce qu'on
a entendu tout à l'heure c'est créer un
6e niveau politico-administratif qui
sera le conseiller métropolitain est-ce
que c'est raisonnable de créer un 6e
niveau
politiadministratif qui est un
conseiller métropolitain ça c'est le
point de vue deunion merci merci
beaucoup monsieur Christiani pour
l'Union des Maires alors maintenant nous
passons à Madame
magaliie
giovanangelli qui est déjà venu nous
voir et qui représente le beau Pays
d'Aubagne et de l'étoile qui nous fait
rêver bien sûr hein tous ces pays des
bouchurau nous font rêver tous parce que
nous aimons beaucoup he votre
département alors Magalie
oui pays d'auagne et de l'étoile mais
comme vous l'a dit marie zoissin
avec une partie particulière on est
vraiment sur des thèmes qu'on a décidé
d'aborder les un et les autres mais qui
lorsqu'on prononce le nom pays d'obagne
de l'étoile confirme ce que vient de
dire George Christi c'està-dire une air
métropolitaine qu'on ne niit pas mais où
on a une vraie diversité de paysages
sociologique et de et de d'installation
et d'occupation du territoire cela étant
je vous remercie de nous recevoir nous
nous sommes vus effectivement euh
lorsque nous nous sommes vus monsieur le
Président vous avez euh prononcé des
phrases et des mots que vous avez
d'ailleurs raelés ce matin comme vous
venez de le dire euh à francebleleu
Provence à la radio qui nous paraisse
particulièrement important le fait que
ce projet de loi tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui dans sa version sa Xe
version doit être profondément modifié
le fait que
euh on peut difficilement faire le bien
des gens malgré eux le fait que le
respect des communes avec votre
expérience que vous aviez évoqué alors
de l'intercommunalité et de 92% des
communes qui se sont regroupées selon la
liberté de choix et le regroupement à
partir de cette volonté en ajoutant
d'ailleurs que la liberté était féconde
nous l'avons effectivement complètement
entendu et complètement intégré dans
notre dans notre réflexion je rappelle
ça parce que c'est c'est important vous
avez rappelé d'ailleurs au début de
votre de notre rencontre aujourd'hui que
l'écoute allit permettre aussi de
d'inscrire sur une page qui pour vous et
pour la commission de loi est blanche et
que nous avons évidemment nous envie de
de de colorer et de colorer avec la
force de ce que vient d'évoquer George
chistiani d'une part nous pensons que la
fusion forcée des communes est la
disparition des
EPCI est une atteinte au principes
constitutionnels de libre administration
des collectivités territoriales teles
que le Sénat l'a voté dans sa résolution
à
l'unanimité ça permet ça pardon ça
empêche particulièrement pour les
communautés d'agloot qui se sont doté de
compétences et pour les communes qui du
coup avec cette loi soit les retrouverai
soit les verrait s'échapper complètement
à la métropole à la fois un problème de
démocratie déjà évoqué mais aussi bien
sûr une vraie question de de compétence
et de réponse aux
besoins je pense que on on a vu aussi
que de ce projet de loi nous avons
entendu un petit bout de ce qui s'est
dit sur Lyon
mais pas Paris mais en tout cas nous en
connaissons quelques éléments en tout
cas l'essentiel il y a de grandes
disparités de traitement entre Paris
Lyon et Marseille et nous ça nous
interpelle particulièrement on a un
dispositif de métropole intégré dans ces
prévisions à l'échelle d'un milion8
d'habitants qui est donc une grosse
grosse partie du département et qui
relègue entre parenthèses la partie
rurale du département au second plan et
qui pourrait créer un désert je le mais
je ne m'étendrai pas d'autres le feront
1008 d'habitants avec une métropole
intégrée qui qui de notre avis est
assassine de tout point de vue d'autant
que nous avons par contre travaillé à
une démarche alternative et à un travail
de coopération métropolitaine qui une
fois de plus je le répète ni ne ni la
nécessité de la coopération ni ne ni
l'aire métropolitaine encore moins la
place de Marseille éprouve si besoin été
qu'on est évidemment pas dans les
Balcans mais qu'on est bien dans un
département qui sait travaillé ensemble
et depuis très longtemps et bien sûr on
a fait le choix des coopérations et du
défi posé à Marseille aujourd'hui parce
que il nous concerne tous
euh dernière dernière petit dernier
petit élément il nous semble que la
solution proposée pour Paris qui est
celle d'un syndicat mixte peut être une
solution qui nous irait parfaitement
celle d'un syndicat mixte qui est
pertinente à la fois parce qu'elle
permet euh au territoire de continuer à
exister parce qu'elle permet aussi euh
de préserver l'outil intercommunal et de
parler de coopération et évidemment euh
elle nous permet d'aborder un certain
nombre de questions que nous avons déjà
évoqué don celle des transports que nous
avons déjà commencé à à aborder et de
nous permettre aussi en préservant les
les euh les territoires existants
d'avoir un outil donc intercommunal qui
permet les coopérations qui permet de
préserver à la fois le droit à la ville
qui euh en terme de proximité de
coopération est important et qui permet
aussi de faire évoluer le rôle des élus
locaux euh dans une République qui peut
les voir évoluer et ça c'est une
question à venir pour nous nous savons
que cette questionl est devant nous et
qu'elle est très importante parce
qu'elle peut faire la différence avec
l'existant et elle peut permettre
lorsque nous nous écoutons les élus
locaux et la capacité des EPCI et des
maires à travailler ensemble de redonner
un rôle un peu différent pour pour nos
nos collectivités locales et donc
j'insiste sur le le le point essentiel
qui est que nous n'acceptons pas euh
d'être traité différemment euh que les
autres grandes villes et les grandes
aires métropolitaines et que le
syndiciste Parisien nous paraît être une
question
importante merci Madame la la
Présidente Monsieur Henri
CAMBACEDES président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération du Pays de martig merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs chers collègues ben merci
de m'accueillir moi je suis très le très
récent président de la commun é d'agloot
du pays de Marti puisque le Président
vous devez le connaître c'est le député
Gabi charou et qui a souhaité me laisser
la place il y a 3 qu jours donc c'est
assez récent mais merci félicitations
merci merci monsieur le Président voilà
non j'interviens parce qu'effectivement
c'est réparti la tâche j'interviens sur
le contexte de la la fiscalité locale
qui serait induit par par la création de
la de la métropole telle que décrite
dans la loi et nous avons travaillé avec
les experts
qui nous ont aidé à définir un petit peu
le contour des modifications de la
fiscalité locale et nous sommes
terriblement
inquiets parce que la résorption des
difficultés financières de MPM pourrait
entraîner la remise en cause des
contributions fiscales des contributions
financière reversé au que les EPCI
reversent à leur commune et ça c'est
aussi vrai pour le pays d'X que pour le
pays pour fosse donc le sestprince Le
Pays d'Aubagne martig et puis le pays de
salon qui est un petit peu plus loin
là-bas je ne parle donc que des des des
cinq des cinq agglomérations qui sont
très directement impactées et concernées
par par le projet actuel euh les
l'évaluation qui a été faite par nos
services financiers porte se monte
jusqu'à 110 millions d'euros j'y
reviendrai un petit peu
et cette hausse des prélèvements fiscaux
sur les habitants sur les entreprises et
les territoires se fait et je tenais à
le rappeler dans un contexte dans le
contexte que vous connaissez tous dans
le contexte d'une d'une crise économique
majeure qui fait que nous avons des
difficultés qui sont à nos portes chacun
d'entre nous le président Caselli en
parlait mais nous vivons aussi la
confrontation à la difficulté économique
et sociale dans dans nos territoires
sachez-le à ce propos j'entendais
monsieur le Président Caselli parler
tout à l'heure en parlant de la
fiscalité métropolitaine et d'une
période de lissage d'une dizaine
d'années je me permets de rappeler
qu'aujourd'hui l'harmonisation fiscale à
la à MPM n'est pas n'est pas aboutie euh
généralement les périodes qui sont
prévues pour ça sont des périodes de 12
ans euh aujourd'hui la période s'achève
et je me posais la question un petit peu
insidieusement si c'était pas une façon
de faire une fuite en avant fiscale que
de demander la prorogation à travers un
nouveau projet métropolitain qui
permettrait d'avoir un rabio de 12
années supplémentaires pour harmoniser
la fiscalité entre les différents
territoires qui composeraient cette
cette agglomération nouvelle euh pour
nous euh donc la création de de cette
PCI de ce nouvel de nouvelle PCI à
fiscalité propre entraînera forcément
l'harmonisation des taux je viens de le
dire et pour la fiscalité des ménages
une réelle difficulté dans la plupart de
nos EPCI actuell je prends à titre
d'exemple j'ai un document que que vous
devez connaître parce que vous êtes vous
aussi issu des des des des territoires
essentiels que sont les communes je
prends les taux communaux et
intercommunaux et en particulier celui
de la taxe d'enlèvement ordure ménagère
celui que nous projetons à nos
concitoyens quand nous votons notre
budget notre budget primitif pour un
Mart égal le taux que nous votons nous
c'est un taux de 0 %. et s'il fallait
harmoniser sur le tau
0 % s'il fallait harmoniser forcément ce
serait au détriment des au détriment des
ménages puisque le taux le plus élevé
dans la strate des grandes villes des
bouches du rô c'est le taux de Marseille
qui est qui était en 2011 à 1780 et qui
me semble-t-il aujourd'hui est à 18 ,1
voilà voilà les inquiétudes qui sont
celles des territoires et c'est pour ça
que nous avons tenu lors de ce petit
cette petite table ronde à vous apporter
à vous apporter certains de ces
éléments concernant la gestion mais je
pense que les Lyonnais l'ont évoqué
aussi la gestion des ressources humaines
et financières la métropole d'ex
Marseille Provence représenterait un
budget de de 2,2 milliards d'euros et
compterait plus de 8000 agents
territoriaux euh aujourd'hui selon
l'étude commandé au Bureau Francis
Lefèvre et suite au rapport de la
Chambre régionale des comptes il
semblerait que MPM ne soit pas parvenu à
régler les problèmes de gestion et par
conséquent serait en difficulté pour
arriver à gérer les 8000 agents dont je
faisais auquels je faisais référence
parce que l'interc l'intercommunalité a
toujours montrer que les harmonisations
en matière de gestion des personnels de
leur statut de leur euh régimes
indemnitaires se faisait forcément par
le haut et que dans ce cadre-là
l'ardoise serait très vite excessive
pour l'ensemble de nos territoires euh
la masse salariale évaluée par nos
services financiers euh de ces 8000
agents représente 300 millions d'euros
si on fait un glissementissement
technicité que vous connaissez tous
quand vous vous traitez ça dans avec vos
personnels dans vos commissions
paritaires et vos commissions euh oui
vos commissions paritaires si on
applique pour la fusion des
EPCI un coefficient de 5 % nous auriions
déjà 15 millions d'euros automatiquement
liés à ce transfert de personnel et à
cette
mise en route donc de de l'harmonisation
des des salaires des uns et des autres
et de leurs régimes indemnitaires voilà
voilà l'inquiétude donc qui est celle
qui nous anime au niveau de nos EPCI je
rappelle tout de même que
nous nous n'instruisons pas à charge ce
dossier nous essayons simplement de
faire valoir quelquesuns des éléments
moi j'avais le besoin de faire valoir
cela non non non non non nous
instruisons pas à charge parce que nous
avons des projets alternatifs monsieur
voilà nous avons des projets alternatifs
qui seront développés qui ont été
développés parce que ceux qui disent que
nous nous sommes pas vus ont tort de le
dire parce que ça fait 2 ans qu'on
travaille là-dessus il y a eu des portes
qui ont claqué comme au théâtre mais bon
des gens qui sont entrés qui sont sortis
nous ce qu'on espère c'est que les les
choses continuent de se passer
comme il convient qu'elle se passe
c'est-à-dire qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
en parler ce que j'aimerais pour
conclure et pour éviter de d'être trop
long c'est que comme vous l'avez fait
pour la région lyonnaise monsieur le
Président vous puissiez venir dans les
bouche du rô vous rendre compte parce
que ça nous ferait très plaisir de vous
savoir présent dans notre territoire qui
est très singulier extrêmement divers
vaste avec des avec des réalités qui
sont à prendre en compte et si vous le
faisiez le plus vite possible ça serait
bien parce que ce serait pour nous plus
plus rassurant qu'autre chose euh voilà
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président serit toujours avec plaisir
bien sûr que nous allons dans les
Bouches du rô alors Monsieur René réondi
maire de fosse surmer et président du
SAN Ouest
Provence bien monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs euh
c'est un trè titre que je vais
m'exprimer sur l'instant sur l'instant
sur l'instant à conseiller général aussi
conseill général cons
général que effectivement euh on a été
un peu attristé de voir que le Conseil
général ne faisait pas partie de de
cette table ronde je sais que vous vous
en êtes
exposé auprès du du Président on s'en
est ému parce qu'on s'est dit au bout
d'un moment parce que si vous voulez
dans un premier temps on avait dit
d'ailleurs tout le monde peut le
constater que on recevait les les
représentants des conseills généraux
après vous et puis bon il y a eu la
forte volonté que le Conseil Général des
Bouches du rô fut représenté donc il est
Monsieur le conseill génal non non non
non je n'y suis pas là à ce titre
simplement pour dire
qu'effectivement nous souhaitons que le
Conseil général soit entendu le moment
tenu contte tenu effectivement qu' ne
peut plus être là ce soir donc d'abord
je crois que beaucoup de gens parlent
des bouches du rô mais connaissent mal
les bouche du Ron euh on on on veut
comparer Paris Marseille et et et Lyon
il est indispensable de faire un petit
retour en arrière je crois que on a
souvent décrit les élus des bouches du
Ron comme de mauvais
élèves il il faut vous sortir ça de
l'idée quoi qu'il en soit moi je suis
président d'un San c'est-à-dire d'une
collectivité qui a aujourd'hui 40 ans
d'existence et donc qui a servi très
certainement à à à ce que de qu'on
puisse ensuite préfigurer les
intercommunalités d'aujourd'hui les
BOUCHES DU Ron restent un département
très très très intégré
où on connaissait seulement neuf
intercommunalités et seulement quatre
villages qui n'avaient pas voulu être
intégrés donc là encore rappeler que
quelque part on a fait figure de bons
élèves on parle aussi souvent du Grand
port maritime de Marseille euh là aussi
on entend tout et n'importe quoi c'est
vrai qu'il y a 50 ans puisque le port
fettera c'est 50 ans en 2013 euh il y a
eu peut-être une erreur une erreur euh
de créer euh le grand port euh à à fosse
à Martigue et à Marseille sans intégrer
ça dans une grande collectivité
territoriale sauf que sauf que depuis 50
ans les choses ont changé que depuis 50
ans des collectivités dont la nôtre dont
celle de martig ont prospéré et ont
essayé encore une fois d'intégrer 7500
haectares sur 9000 pour la ville de Fos
surmer un grand port maritime à
l'intérieur d'un territoire avec toutes
les souffrances que ça a pu provoquer je
rappelle que une partie de ce grand port
est aujourd'hui euh dans la réserve
naturelle de camarg ça parle à certains
comme ça ça situe un petit peu mieux le
le problème rappelez aussi que le Grand
port maritime de Marseille est géré est
géré par un directoire le Directoire est
nommé par un Conseil des ministres et là
on va commencer à toucher les
incohérences du système première
incohérence du système MPM aujourd'hui
n'est pas représenté au conseil de
surveillance c'est la ville de Marseille
pourquoi comment on s'est pas euh on
parle des bassins est aujourd'hui les
bassins est c'est Marseille les bassins
ouest c'est Fos surmer et moi je
découvre au fil des jours une
transformation de mes bassins ouest qui
deviennent au quotidien de plus en plus
équipés qui commence à accueillir de
plus en plus de de bateaux et puis euh
des bassins est qui petit à petit voient
arriver au pied au pied du siège du
Grand port maritime de Marseille on a
aujourd'hui la construction d' centre
commercial sur l'qu donc bon je sais pas
moi je je je je commence à m'inquiéter
on commence à me dire effectivement ça
peut pas fonctionner un port qui est sur
plusieurs intercommunalités mais je sens
bien queà côté il y a
effectivement une ville qui a une force
particulière et qui est en train de
faire changer ce grand port maritime
donc là aussi il y a une incohérence
dans les propos moi je veux bien qu'on
Contin continu à développer un port mais
il faut lui donner les moyens il y a
quelques jours j'étais sur l'île de la
Réunion l' de la Réunion c'est un réseau
automobile un réseau de de de de de
route formidable tout est neuf et puis
je retourne à Fos surmer et je me
retrouve à nouveau confronté à mes
difficultés un grand port maritime qui
aujourd'hui est desservi par une route
départementale au départ elle était
nationale on l'a redonné au département
le département est en train de faire ce
qu'il faut pour faire sa
partie aujourd'hui on n' pas commencé à
travailler
sur comment on va évacuer les 5 millions
de boîtes qui devraient arriver à à
fosse surmer avant 2020 et ça on vient
le reprocher aux élus locaux excusez-moi
il y a eu des choix pour la Réunion on
n' pas fait les mêmes apparemment pour
développer les BOUCHES DU Ron donc là
moi je pointe du doigt ceux qui ont fait
ces erreurs là c'est pas les élus locaux
c'est l'État qui a pas fait son travail
aujourd'hui pour sortir les contenairs
vous avez une voie ferrée unique
c'est-à-dire que lorsque vous voulez
évacuer effectivement des contenir vous
attendez que le train qui est sur la
voie soit passé pour envoyer l'autre
alors je vous rassure ça évolue ça
avance on va peut-être effectivement
évoluer et puis au fil du temps cette
belle zone industrielle que nous avions
mais c éolé cé étolier pourquoi parce
qu'on a donné le pouvoir d'aménagement
au Grand port maritime de Marseille sur
cette zone et le Grand port maritime de
Marseille n'avait qu'une vision la
vision est effectivement du trafic
portuaire or cette zone a vécu de la
cidérurgie a vécu effectivement de la
pétrochimie et aujourd'hui dans les
difficultés que qu'on rencontre au
niveau de la chirurgie et de la
pétrochimie on se rend compte qu'on a
oublié les filières aval mais là encore
les filières aval oui mais là encore
c'est pas les élus locaux qui ont fait
l'erreur c'est ceux c'est les éénarques
et et et les xxepons du passé parce que
aujourd'hui c'est un éarc dans le passé
c'était les xxepons qui étaient là
effectivement à la direction du port
n'ont pas voulu entendre effectivement
ce qui ce qui ce qui ce qui devait être
fait dans ce dossier on est face à un
dénis de démocratie je crois que le mot
est important je le redis 109 mèes sur
119 sont contre alors vous me direz le
petit maire de fosse sur mer que je suis
est habitué au dénis de
démocratie la communauté urbaine de
Marseille est venu construire et c'est
la première fois que c'est arrivé en
France un incinérateur qui qu'elle n'a
pas eu le courage politique de faire sur
son territoire elle est allé le faire
chez le voisin avec la complicité des
services de l'État voilà ce qu'on est en
train de revivre aujourd'hui à une
échelle plus monumentale au niveau
effectivement de ce projet de loi alors
pointer du doigt quelques incohérence
aussi de de de cette loi on nous parle
effectivement d'une mise en place au 1er
janvier 2015 bien pourquoi nous on est
on est content que ça se passe en 2015
plutôt qu'en 2014 mais là on touche déjà
du du doigt une loi d'exception on sait
pas pourquoi d'ailleurs on doit on doit
on doit porter le péché originel je sais
je ne sais quoi pour que on soit puni de
de telle sorte là aussi le libre choix
vous l'avez bien compris n'existe pas
chez nous puisque dans le principe de
l'intercommunalité il y avait bien le
libre choix d'être associé ou non là on
nous dit non non non vous avez pas le
choix vous irez
obligatoirement dans cette communauté
urbaine qui ne vous veut que du bien que
du bien bien évidemment euh euh la le
caractère dérogatoire est tout le long
de de ce dossier euh et et et et et on
aurait des heures pour pour essayer
effectivement euh de de le pointer du
doigt euh dans le projet qui a été euh
porté au Conseil d'État euh il y avait
euh de manière dérogatoire beaucoup
beaucoup de choses ça a été réduit euh
par rapport à ce qui a été porté euh au
Conseil des ministres donc on imagine
que le Conseil d'État on ne fait que
l'imaginer bien évidemment euh a demandé
un certain nombre de de modifications
mais des modifications euh qui continue
à à à laisser planer ce ce régime
dérogatoire quoi qu'il en soit
euh là aussi quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire on nous dit non mais ne
vous inquiétez pas sur vos territoires
vous allez avoir des conseils de
territoire euh et qui qui prendront le
périmètre des EPCI actuels et puis si
vous voulez qu'on en discute on va en
discuter et et ça ça sera
obligatoirement en place et cetera sauf
qu'on découvre que lorsque ça passe chez
au Conseil des ministres ça a disparu
c'est-à-dire que l'intercommunalité
pourra le faire ou ou ou ou pas le faire
si elle en a envie ou si elle n'a pas
envie et puis ça sera le Conseil d'État
qui fixera les limites donc on sait plus
entre ce que dit Madame le Ministre et
et le texte de loi ce qui va ce qui va
se passer l'autonomie financière elle
aussi pour ces conseils de de quarti on
va dire puisqueon va devenir tous des
quartiers de Marseille euh alors là on
la connaît plus puisque véritablement
euh l'investissement disparaî les
dotations d'investissement disparaissent
les les dotations de fonctionnement on
espère effectivement qu'elles vont
rester au niveau où elles sont mais on
sait pas on sait pas et puis après on
arrive aux compétences alors là sur sur
ce point c'est pas la peine de vous
épuiser on a rencontré Laurent Terry ce
matin et donc nous on sait complètement
bien formidable j'espère que vous nous
direz euh ça sera bien comme ça euh donc
14 14 compétences on nous renvoie 14
compétences alors on avait bien compris
que on était pas bon à la gestion et que
donc on allait avoir des compétences de
gestion fortes et puis le texte encore
une fois quand il arrive au Conseil des
ministres ces compétences ne sont plus
en gestion on voit apparaître des
schémas des plans et on sait plus
effectivement ce ce qu'il va y avoir
effec d'opérationnel à l'intérieur de de
de de de cette nouvelle métropole qui va
se créer vous comprendrez que là on
commence à avoir encore des doutes mais
bien évidemment madame la ministre nous
rassure à chaque fois mais mais entre
effectivement un texte qui dit des
choses et un ministre qui semble dire
pas tout à fait la même chose on
commence à à se poser de de graves
questions dernière chose j'en arrête
là la complexité du du
dispositif l'élection municipale va se
passer en 2014 aujourd'hui dans l'état
actuel des choses les 6
intercommunalités qui sont concerné ça
représente
417 représentant normalement élection
municipal il va y avoir des fléchages
sauf pour les dinosaures que nous sommes
le S puisque là il y a pas de fléchage
donc on sait pas trop comment ça va se
passer pour
nous on flèche normalement ces gensl
sont fléchés pour être élus dans un
conseil jusqu'à 2020
au début on nous a parlé de 180
représentants d'un coup on se retrouve
avec 417 de la même manière les
présidents de PCI et les vice-présidents
de PCI qui vont être élus en avril 2014
que deviendront-ils donc voilà voilà
voilà d'autres incohérences qui sont du
Doig merci hein parce que vous avez une
ferveur d'avocat je sais pas si vous
êtes avocat vous pourriez
l'être oui justement je voulais vous
dire deux choses même trois premièrement
il n'a pas de petit maire je vois pas
pourquoi être maire de fosse sur mer
c'est très important pour la République
comme d'être maire de chacune des 36700
communes permettez-moi de vous dire que
j'ai connu malheureusement le poids et
la force d'un État jacobin qui est venu
m'imposer sur un territoire c'est pour
çaessement au vous comprenez nous
sénateurs qui devons aller
crapahuter madame Gouro là dans nos
villages
pour nous faire élire voie par voie vous
savez il y a pas de petit MRE si je voir
un petit MRE dire si je suis un petit
merre je vais voter pour quelqu'un
d'autre ben ça c'est clair on n pas de
petit m deuxièmement que je suis assez
très intéressé je me permet de dire
parce que vous dites sur les territoires
parce que je dis que faut pas non plus
que on s'encombre la tête de trop de
réunions à non plus finir parce que si
vous avez la
commune la communauté la métropole et
après les territoires à l' érieur de la
métropole oui je sais bien oui mais nous
on est libre on va faire on s'instruit
de ce que vous dites les uns et les
autres mais il faut pas que ce soit
casse-tête quoi parce que quand si je
vais lundi à la réunion de la mairie le
mardi à la réunion de la communauté le
mercredi à la réunion de la métropole le
jeudi à la réunion du conseil de
territoire le vendredi j'arrête quoi je
dis
écoutez alors maintenant je vais devoir
don monter
c'est madame Sophie joissin qui prendra
la présidente mais je vais donner la
parole à Marie joissin maire d'ex en
Provence et puis après à Olivier guirou
et puis après monsieur Menucci et puis
après monsieur petit madame Gali puis
nos deux rapporteurs puis madame la
présidente de la délégation puis
monsieur Paul vinelli car il serait
impensable que dans une telle réunion
monsieur Paul vinelli ne parla point
donc et Monsieur Gill aussi pourra
parler mais mais mais mais Monsieur Paul
vinelli nous connaissons son calme bon
alors madame le Maire d'ex en Provence
oui c'est votre belle ville monsieur le
Président comme vous avez pu le le
constater nous sommes avant tous c'est
un effort de calme mais de synthèse mais
non mais moi je trouve pas que vous
soyez parti vous êtes plein de vie et
c'est ce qui est bien dans votre
département nous on aime les les gens
des bouches du rô ah oui al allez-y oui
euh avec le tempérament qui est celui de
chacun d'entre nous monsieur le
Président vous comprenez à quel point
nous nous sommes fait violence pour
arriver coordonn ici alors que nous
sommes plein de violence par rapport à
une loi qui nous agresse chaque fois que
l'on en parle et chaque fois qu'on
rencontre un
responsable de cette loi euh du
ministère que ce soit le préfetterie
d'ailleurs euh que nous rencontrons
régulièrement qui est un monsieur
charmant mais qui nous dit des choses
absolument incroyables une loi dont on
image on imagine vraiment pas par qui
elle a pu être écrite tellement elle est
technocratique tellement elle elle
multiplie les problèmes tellement elle
est isible et tellement elle va créer
des difficultés en tout cas les juristes
que que je suis ou ou les avocats que
nous sommes pour certains d'entre nous
seront ravis parce qu'il y aura matière
à faire du judiciaire et matière à avoir
des problèmes lorsquon écrit une loi il
faut qu'elle soit lisible et il faut
qu'elle soit cohérente ce qui n'est pas
le cas de cette loi alors moi j'ai
choisi d'intervenir uniquement sur deux
points étant donné que mes collègues
développent tous au fur et à mesure un
problème moi je voulais vous parler des
accusations que l'on a porté contre nous
et qui sont absolument fausses je veux
en parler parce que je considère que si
l'on ne crève pas l'absé on est toujours
suspect de quelque chose et par voix de
conséquence on est mal peu ou po entendu
d'abord on a dit les maires ils veulent
rester sur leurs acquis il veulent
rester sur leurs avantages et ils ne
discutent sur rien alors je crois pvoir
vous dire Monsieur le Président que dès
la loi sarzy que j'ai combattu comme je
aujourd'hui la loi Hollande et ça m'a
pas été absolument favorable dans dans
le déroulement des faits qui qui ont
suivi je me suis batue tu le sais
puisque le ministre que tu étais à
l'époque là l'a vécu
et je me suis batue parce que j'avais
conscience qu'il fallait revoir la carte
des collectivités territoriales qu'il
fallait revoir la carte de notre
territoire
mais qu'il fallait le faire de façon
apaisée droite gauche et centre réunie
parce qu'on ne discute pas là d'une
idéologie politique on discute là en
terme d'efficacité en terme de
compétitivité par rapport à l'étranger
par rapport aux autres pays et
immédiatement lorsque la CDCI a été
constituée les intercommunalités du
territoire qui sont au nombre de 9 et
pas de 6 comme on veut bien nous faire
croire aujourd'hui dans la constitution
d'une métropole qui sera forcément
incomplète nous nous sommes battus pour
travailler ensemble et présenter une
alternative la loi Sarkozi nous offrait
une alternative entre la métropole et le
pôle métropolitain nous avons choisi
bien entendu le pôle métropolitain et
nous avons commencé à travailler
ensemble pour essayer de dire ce que
nous voulions et ce que nous étions
prêts à accepter AC peut-être sur des
échéances pour ce territoire nous avons
travaillé profondément et toujours dans
le cadre de cette loi Sarkozi il fallait
fin 2012 que nous puissions choisir si
nous prenions le parti de la métropole
le parti du pôle métropolitain nous
avons tous ensemble toutes les
intercommunalités je reviendrai 2
secondes sur la tienneugène nous avons
tous ensemble voté pour le pôle
métropolitain et tous nos conseils
municipaux ont voté pour le pôle
métropolitain montrant par la même que
nous étions ouverts à une coopération
métropolitaine mais cette coopération
métropolitaine doit pas être n'importe
quoi et être écrite n'importe
comment lorsque le gouvernement de
Monsieur Holland est arrivé au pouvoir
les socialistes de la
région les socialistes des bougiron tous
étaient ravis parce que ça voulait dire
on abandonne cette métropole que nous
avons stigmatisé que nous avons V pandé
et patatra on nous met une métropole
plus dure où là il y a pas de choix là
il y a pas de choix il y a pas de choix
avant il y avait un pôle métropolitain
où on pouit avancer à notre vitesse là
il y a pas de choix on est tué d'emblé
et nous avons des des des grands fon ir
nationaux qui vont pendre un truc
inommable c'est une proposition de loi
qui est contraire totalement à l'esprit
de la République et qui est contraire
totalement à l'indépendance et
collectivité territorial et qui enterre
la belle loi qu'avait pondu monsieur
defer et qui est une loi équilibrée qui
voulait aller contre le centralisme
excessif parce que moi je vais vous le
confier monsieur le Président quand à
avoir un centralisme je préfère que ce
soit le centralisme d'État parce que le
centralisme d'État il est toujours à peu
près neutre ça qu'un centralisme local
vous aboutissez à la féodalité à des
potentas locaux à du clientélisme et
puis après ils peuvent tous aller par
Charre chez les juges d'instruction
j'attire votre attention monsieur le
Président a quand même pas une tête de
je vais je vais je suis peut-être
excessive parce que mes collègues en PR
la parole m'ont chauffé m'ont chauffé
petit à petit mais mais j'attire votre
attention monsieur le Président et mais
je mets pas en cause l'honnêteté de gêne
qui est proverbial et qui et qui ben je
l'ai pas fait bon alors calme-toi donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que Monsieur
monsieur le Président l'ancien régime
avait des féodalité les royaumes de
France sen est débarrassé et a fait
l'état français après nous avons fait la
décentralisation et nous l'avons réussi
aujourd'hui on est en train de faire de
la
recentralisation ça c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire et attirer votre
attention sur ce que diront ceux qui
vont venir après après nous de cette loi
médiocre que l'on est en train de nous
soumettre alors monsieur le Président
vous avez compris nous sommes pour la
coopération méop poain nous l'avons dit
nous le redisons et les maires les
maires des bouchuron se sont unis on
vous l'a dit tout à l'heure à 109 sur
119 pour repousser non pas la
coopération métropolitaine mais pour
repousser le texte parce que nous avons
tous dit et nous sommes tous d'accord
sur ces éléments là que nous étions pour
que la compétence stratégique les
compétences stratégiques qui son les
transports le développement économique
l'aménagement du territoire soit confié
à une structure qui couvre tout le
territoire et en exerçant ces
compétences stratégiques et les moyens
de le faire on prendra sur les dotations
où il faut prendre mais ça aura une
cohérence et puis après pourquoi aller
passer toutes les compétences y compris
les compétences du cimetière et de
l'état civil à la même structure qui va
s'
qui n'aura aucune efficacité qui n'aura
aucune efficacité parce que la loi est
mal écrite elle est mal construite elle
est elle est totalement arbitraire et
vous avez fini discuter tous les deux
c'est moi qui parle voilà alors non tu
as pas rectifié pendant que je le dis
voilà ce qu'on veut dire on est d'accord
avec Eugène on est d'accord
avec il est passé pas du
tout on est d'accord avec les
Marseillais on est d'accord pour cette
coopération métropolitaine on veut
qu'elle s'exerce sur des compétences
stratégiques et que l'on trouve une
formule juridique pour les autres
compétences qui restent aux communes et
celles qui peuvent rester ou aux
intercommunalités ou à une autre manière
de fonctionner peu importe c'est à vous
de trouver la formulation juridique pour
qu'il y ait une distinction entre les
compétences stratégiques et les
compétences au quotidien alors sur la
deuxème
partie sur la deuxème partie que je
voulais dont je voulais vous parler
monsieur le Président on dit que nous
sommes contre Marseille et que nous ne
voulons pas assumer une solidarité par
rapport à Marseille on n'est pas fana
mais on y va et on y va franchement et
de façon loyale et on le dit à Eugène on
le dit à meni on le dit à tous les
marseillais on n'est pas là on n'est pas
là je regarde le Président on n pas là
pour aller contre Marseille et dire on
veut pas aider Marseille on est d'accord
pour travailler dans le cadre dans le
cadre des pôles métropolitains on est on
est d'accord pour travailler avec
Marseille mais pas n'importe quel prix
parce que monsieur le Président ce que
l'on essaie de nous faire avaler c'est
que Marseille a des déficits très
important et qu'avec ce qu'il y a comme
argent sur l'arrière du département on
va combler les déficit de Marseille
c'est pas à l'échelle c'est avoir
vis-à-vis de Marseille un comportement
indécent parce que Marseille mérite
mieux nous sommes tous d'accord pour ce
que Marseille devienne la capitale des
villes de la Méditerranée et elle le
mérite et elle peut l'être à condition
que l'État a de Marseille mais ce sont
pas les moyens pris sur le reste du
territoire qui vont y suffire ça va
entraîner la désorganisation ça va
entraîner des problèmes à tous les les
niveaux et simplement pour en terminer
parce que je voudrais pas avoir abusé du
temps qui m'était
imparti monsieur le Président cette loi
même si elle est pendue
elle sera pas appliquée
elle sera pas appliquée pour une raison
très simple c'est que quand vous avez
109 mères qui sont contre sur 119 et
dans les mères qui sont compte vous en
avez 12 de MPM sur 19 et la population
marseillaise n'a pas a été consulté non
plus on dit qu'elle est pour mais elle a
pas été consultée non plus et moi je
peux vous dire Monsieur le Président
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous travaillons
dans le calme des élus parce que nous
sommes en année préélectorale et qu'on
peut pas faire encore appel à la
population on peut pas faire appel au
monde économique qui a ex et dans le
pays d'ex est contre cette métropole
nous pouvons pas faire appel aux acteurs
pourquoi parce que tout simplement nous
serions tous inéligibles c'est c'est la
loi qui le prévoit mais pourquoi elle
sera pas appliqué cette loi parce que la
population au-delà des élus ne la voudra
pas et j'en terminerai par là monsieur
le Président en vous disant que le
territoire des boujurones est un
territoire multipolaire il y a neuf
poôle et lui il en fait partie il est
pas venu à la dernière réunion je suis
désolé qu'il soit plus là pour
m'entendre il est venu à toutes les
réunions sur le pôle métropolitain quand
c'était la loi Sarkozi à partir du
moment où ça a été la loi Hollande il
est parti il a plus assisteré aux
réunions qui était les nôtres et que
nous organisions toute tendance
politique
confondu voilà j'en aurais terminé
monsieur le Président Madame le Maire et
je précise bien que aucune loi n'est
votée aucune loi n'est imposée il y a un
projet de loi et entre le projet de loi
et la loi il va se couler beaucoup d'eau
sous les ponts alors madame la
présidente'ensiv merci monsieur le
président
je non d'abord Monsieur Olivier guirou
maire de la phar les oliviers et
vice-président d'aglopole Provence merci
merci de me laisser la parole c'est très
compliqué d'intervenir après mes
collègues et surtout juste après Marise
mais je vais essayer de faire de mon
mieux parce que elle a a résumé c'est
vrai l'inquiétude qu'on ressent je je
vais parler surtout en tant que maire et
quand je parle en tant que maire et
quand on parle des 109 maires du
département qui sont contre cette loi
c'est pas en tant je parle pas de mon
poste de maire mais je parle vraiment
pour ma commune et je pense que la
gravité de ce qui nous est proposé va
atteindre nos administrés et c'est pour
ça que je vous voudrait m'exprimer je
crois que maris a bien résumé on est
tous d'accord pour une coopération
autour de Marseille on sait que les
transports ça fonctionne pas on sait
qu'il y a un certain nombre de choses
qui ne fonctionnent pas les les les
grands axes stratégiques il faut les
faire effectivement avec Marseille on
est tous d'accord maintenant c'est vrai
qu'après ce qui est prévu ça nous
inquiète parce que comme l'a dit maris
c'est une recentralisation et ça ne
correspond pas pour ce que j'avais
entendu quand je suis venu au Congrès
des Maires le dernier à ce qu'a dit le
président quand il a dit qu'on
préserverai les communes et dans ce
système que je vois là j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on va préserver les
communes pourquoi transférer si tu
permets que je continue pourquoi
transférer les cimetières pourquoi
transférer la voirie systématiquement
c'està-dire que la voirie moi je suis un
maire de proximité hein c'est-à-dire que
les gens viennent me voir et me disent
écoute mon trottoir tu permets que je je
parle excuse-moi je cherche les cimtiè
c'est pas vrai et si ça y est dedans tu
tu as le droit mais tu es pas obligé de
faireés mais ça y
estat oui je crois voilà tout le monde
se calme on laisse l'interlocuteur
parler est-ce que je peux est-ce que je
peux continuer madame la Présidente donc
si on nous effectivement reste reste
calme Patrick attends laisse-moi
récupérer mon
styend ton tour estprès P tu vas
intervenir Monsieur Olivier guiroume tu
va intervenir surtout voter à
l'Assemblée nationale t'inquiète pas oui
mais bon donc voilà moi je je voudrais
refaire part de cette inquiétude que je
ressens en tant que maire au nom de ma
commune je le répète par rapport à ce
qui va disparaître je pense aussi et on
en a parlé et c'est vrai l'augmentation
des de la fiscalité elle est obligatoire
je vois pas mais alors je veux vraiment
qu' me l'explique comment on va faire
pour se passer de cette augmentation de
la fiscalité à terme pour moi c'est
impossible c'est-à-dire que quand on
prend la taxe d'enlèvement des ordures
ménagère quand on prend la fiscalité
additionnelle la fiscalité des ménages
comment est-il possible que nous y a une
fiscalité inférieure on va se mettre à
notre niveau c'est pas vrai dans la
future intercommunalité c'est pas
possible et on perd la proximité quand
je dis tout à l'heure donc je voudlais
finir mon propos là-dessus je suis un
maire qui essaie d'être un maire de
proximité c'est-à-dire que par par
exemple il se trouve que c'est le mardi
mais aujourd'hui j'étais obligé de venir
ici le mardi après-midi je reçois tous
les citoyens de ma commune sans
rendez-vous ils viennent me voir et ils
me disent j'ai un trou sur mon trottoir
tu l'as pas réparé il y a un trou sur la
chaussée viens le réparer il y a un
passage protégé à faire il y a un pont
de rupture de vitesse à faire on aura
plus tout ça tout ça va partir et
excuse-moi c'est écrit aussi les
cimetières l'état civil tout est écrit
dans la loi déjà alors qu'on nous
confirme que effectivement et c'est ce
qu'on nous dit chaque fois ce ne seront
que les grands axes stratégiques je veux
bien le croire mais pour l'instant je le
crois pas parce que je vois ce que je
vois dans la loi c'est l'inverse hein
qui est prévu les 14 compétences qui
vont disparaître ça va passer de l'autre
côté et si en plus au-delà de ça au-delà
de ça on perd le plu hein moi je veux
bien les les interscottes c'est normal
un interplh je suis vice-président
chargé de l'habitat ça me semble logique
qu' devienne métropolitain là j'y vois
pas d'opposition un interp PDU ça me
semble aussi logique maintenant renvoyer
les PLU sur une énorme structure encore
une fois et le faire perdre cet
aménagement du territoire cette gestion
de notre territoire parce que c'est
franchement je pense que c'est nous qui
le connaissons le mieux ce sont les
maires qui connaissent le mieux leur
territoire c'est moi qui sais ce qui se
passe dans ma zone agricole et qui
essaie au jour le jour de la protéger
parce que je sais que dans 30 ou 50 ans
les enjeux agricoles seront monumentaux
et qu'il faudra avoir eu avoir eu la
possibilité d'avoir protégé ces espaces
là d'ici là mais là ce qu'on nous
propose non c'est l'inverse et qu'est-ce
qu'on va créer et maris a raison une
fois qu'on aura appliqué cette cette
métropole elle marchera pas et on ce
sera trop tard et on se dira c'est pas
possible comment peut-on imposer à sa ne
mère des bouches d' Ron quelque chose
qui refuse absolument voilà pour les
travaux de la commission des lois si
vous souhaitez les revoir ils sont
disponibles en VOD sur notre site
internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
les travaux parlementaires c'est cet
après-midi à partir de 14h45 pour suivre
en direct les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement bonne journée à
tous